Excuse me, but black men getting the vote, I'm just going to
see as a moral good. Women getting the vote, we could argue about.
I don't really care. >> Why do you think black people getting
the vote was bad? This is why Connor's wife controls none of
the finances. Okay. He doesn't believe in women's suffrage. He
doesn't believe in women's right to self-determination.
Oh, here we go. Counterpoints politics. Okay, let's go. >> Network.
I would I also do counterpoints 40k. Uh counterpoints 40k is
breaking down the wonder world wonder wonderful world of Warhammer.
Um so I love science fiction and then also I do politics on list
mixed economy capitalist empire. I think that
um and so what I would say is that we see Christian nationalisms
uh Christian nationalism and the rightwing raising up and I think
that necessarily within that definition is a ideological supremacy.
Uh that doesn't >> Oh yes. So um they're debating Christian
nationalism. Andrew Wilson obviously taking the pro. Connor taking
the the against. Okay. Or whatever. He's he's anti-Christian
nationalism.
So
I don't know where this usually I don't know where this is going
to go with big papa fascist. He normally argues down what line?
I guess it's divine command theory. And then he talks about how
I have not watched him in a long time. We'll see where it goes.
It'll all start clicking again. I haven't watched one of these
debates in a long time. >> There's obviously better ideas
than other ideas, but we have to argue about whether or not those
ideas are true. Um, so I had this conversation with Jim Bob the
other day. Uh, we don't necessarily have to talk about the Trinity,
but realistically, if we're basing a political ideology off of
something, I think that the foundation of that ideology should
probably be true, like like factually true. So, we can get into
theology and all that kind of stuff. Uh, when it comes to United
States of America, I actually think that liberalism is a pretty
successful
>> I sure hope Pisco helped Connor prepare. Oh, maybe he's
taking pro liberalism >> I think we're the largest economy.
I think that would be quite hard for Connor because that's probably
where BPF does like Andrew Wilson I should say Andrew Wilson
that's probably where Andrew Wilson does his best work is arguing
with people on like why liberalism is bad like he that's the
debate he has literally like every day for the past 9 years right
liberalism is bad because on the planet I think we run a successful
hegemonic
capitalist mixed economy capitalist empire I think that our military
is the most powerful on the planet. I think we're effectively
the new Rome. Um, I think that our civilizational achievements,
if you actually measure them, are pretty gosh darn impressive.
And I look at the Cold War, World War II, World War I, the 19th
century, uh, with a lot of pride. And, uh, Andrew Wilson's debate
topic is just basically or debate tactics basically always pointing
this out, right?
No like societal principles, no duties. As long as you don't
cause harm, we don't criticize you, right? This is this is Andrew
Wilson's general debate strategy.
>> Uh Thomas Jefferson, one of our founders who who set
up this entire liberal libertarian project. Um he actually he
was pretty specific and and intention. >> I listen I feel
like I want to try to get through Connor's opening. I feel like
listening to Connor rant about just so
quibble I'm sorry. Should form a people with unified interest
to use the state to promote it. I would I would quibble a bit
with the definition of should.
Um I don't think that the president ought or you must. I do think
that Christian nationalism does want to use the state to promote
the interests of Christians. I think that that's correct. Uh
as far as political ideology being true or the Trinity, I don't
know what that has to do with anything. Um the Constitution's
not true.
>> Yeah. Through Conor's opening. God damn. Jefferson,
one of our founders who who set up this entire liberal libertarian
>> Um, yeah, Koser, I literally, you might have just tuned
in, but that's what I said is I think Connor struggles in debates
against conservatives because he is a joke to conservatives.
He's a total hypocrite. He's a loser and he'll support whatever
predator will get him the most clicks and views and money so
he can try to make it as an influencer.
>> Yeah. So, I would imagine that makes him a joke to most
people who are remotely conservative.
Now, I don't think he's wrong about hating Trump. I think he's
correct, but I think you can argue why you should hate Trump
from the framework of somebody who's actually conservative, right?
I don't know how he does it necessarily. I think by ali uh aligning
yourself, allying yourself with, you know, prominent liberal
degenerates, probably a lot of these people just look at you
as a total [__] joke and that's understandable. Kind
of makes sense. Um, he actually, >> I don't know if you
ever saw Koser, by the way, any of his debates that he went when
he was trying to defend Destiny, any of the times he actually
went and debated with people, he sounded like a complete [__]
>> Thinks he's being Mchavelian.
I don't even think he thinks he's being mchy. He's like actually
coped himself into believing that if I make money, um, that's
like morally good. It's like a moral good if I make money cuz
bad people are making the money now. So, if I'm a good person,
I make money. even if I have to do bad things, then I'm a good
person who can make a difference later. It's like the exact thing
that everybody who goes into politics, anybody who tries to do
charity work on like a large scale, right? And then the idea
of corruption creeps in and you go, "Oh, I can do a little bit
to make sure my dreams come true." And as soon as you make those
changes, as soon as you let go of your principles in order to
make a quick buck, it just snowballs. Okay.
>> he was pretty specific and and intentional informing
the first amendment that he believed that Muhamadans uh he believed
that Muslims and he believed that could be tolerated under the
system and uh yeah so so I think American civic nationalism is
superior to Christian nationalism. I think Christian nationalism
is probably to some degree contrary to the American project and
uh I'll leave it there and we can dig into it further later on.
All right. Thank you very much for the uh for that opener, Connor.
And uh so uh Andrew, whenever you're ready, we can
>> Yeah, there's not a lot of meat.
>> Who's the moderator with the um with like the AI Thanksgiving
thing in the background? I've never heard of this guy >> On
the bone here. Um
so the belief that Christians
uh I'm sorry, should form a people with unified interest to use
the state to promote it. I would I would quibble a bit with the
definition of should. Um, I don't think that the position of
the ought or must. I do think that Christian nationalism
does want to use the state to promote the interests of Christians.
I think that that's correct. Uh, as far as political ideology
being true or the Trinity, I don't know what that has to do with
anything. Um, the Constitution's not true, right? That's not
uh unless you're just unless you're kind of making the statement
that um well the constitution is true in the sense that the axioms
that we came up with and the rights that we socially constructed
are true because we follow them. If that's the case then
would just true if we followed it or didn't follow it. Right?
So I'm not sure um you know what we're what we're using as a
truth claim on that. As far as uh some of the other points, these
are just kind of basic liberal points, Connor. Uh you have the
largest economy on the planet. That's true. That's because it's
a very resourcerrich
nation. Uh which was was only recently colonized in the last
few hundred years and it's completely landlocked across the ocean
and so our enemies have no access. >> I've never heard
a a person describe a continent as landlocked before. That's
kind of funny >> to us. And in North America, we did fight
some wars between >> like technically Hawaii is landlocked,
but I I've never heard anybody describe it that way >> between
us and South American nations, but again, we're highly resource
rich. So that was that's the main reason.
>> In fact, that's just not how you use that word at all,
is it? Like landlocked, I would assume means you're bordered
by land on all sides. It's like the opposite of
I could have sworn landlocked meant you have land. Yeah, you're
surrounded entirely by land. So, it's the opposite of Yeah, that's
bizarre.
>> Very bizarre. >> Uh that we're the largest economy
on the planet. Honestly, it's not because of any liberal ideology.
I would contend that if you had who took this whole place over
uh and had access to all the resources that would still probably
be
>> resource rich is something different than what I I
there are resources. There was a lot of oil down south in Texas,
but I don't think it's that it's like Africa is super is maybe
even more resourcerich if you say it in the normal sense like
um metals
and just general like you know you mine it or you refine it,
anything like that. Africa is more resources.
It's
we watched we watched exactly what it was. Okay. The navigable
rivers and the natural harbors. >> The largest economy
on the planet. He says the military's most powerful. Well, it
kind of should be because it again we're landlocked and have
access to a huge huge amount of resources.
Um, as far as achievements being impressive, I agree that the
achievements of the United States have been very impressive.
I'm just not so sure that that has anything to do with liberalism
as to why they're so impressive. Uh, he says that Jefferson's
necessary to the liberal uh project. I do think that even if
if the US had formed as an autotocracy of some kind like a monarchy
or something, I do believe the US could have taken off. It probably
always had to start as like some form of mercantalism.
But transitioning from the mercantalist like system they had
where it was, you know, a ton of traders, people like privateeers
making a ton of money into a country.
I think that could have possibly happened under a king. You don't
get quite the same level of free market innovation in that case.
I don't know. Maybe not. It would depend something like a like
you need the you need the embrace of capitalism in the same way
like like basically I think if fascists took it over with the
with the like if not if took it over I think they would have
done a lot with it basically
right but you need to have the idea that like hey we're going
to elevate people of intelligence people who innovate need like
that part from capitalism to make sure it succeeds.
I mean kind of I guess uh who said that Muhammadans and and people
could be here. That's true. But he definitely did not prioritize
them at all. >> Like in no way, shape or form did any of
the DAS prioritize Muhammadons
uh or uh in fact Jefferson ended up >> I saw this comment
coming from Stalin sloth and I pre-fired it and won
fighting a war um with the Barbar States and uh you know this
this did not end well for the Barbar States and as you guys know
those were Muslims. So um if we can get into the Treaty of Tripoli
and what the entailments were there if he wants to but the entailment
there for the Treaty of Tripoli was not secularism either. It
was just a practical compromise and that's why later forms of
this treaty don't actually have the uh the secular standard of
not Christian nation. So, I don't really know what he's talking
about there. Ultimately, I would just say this. The reason that
the this argument or this debate's happening at all has nothing
really to do it has to do with just one like status quo versus
non-status quo. Counterpoints is a status quo guy. I get that.
I understand that. But kind of the problem is is that his form
of liberalism is uh a liberalism which exists only >> talk
about counterpoints herm that's weird. Oh he usually does his
best law counting with this look maybe bro I turned on Queen's
stream today what happened with him what he what oh no not today
yesterday. I turned on Queen's stream yesterday. What was going
on with the hair there? Anybody check that out? What do we have
going on? What the Did he take the bowl to the barbers or does
the barber have a bowl for him?
like in
our founders didn't >> I'm sorry. It's uh it was a goofy
haircut. Okay. It looked like a goofy >> Not have any of
this.
>> I I don't even I don't even want to talk because he'll
come in and talk back and he'll be better at it. Okay. I don't
even necessarily want to talk, but it's super funny. It was super
funny when I >> Not intentioned at all. And we're >> I'm
not pulling that [__] up. I'm not doing that. Okay.
This guy I'll this guy will start a logging all my streams if
I pull that up and make fun of him openly on my stream. Okay,
I ain't doing that. >> Where most liberals go from universal
suffrage completely destroyed any idea that this guy has of a
liberal project
any sort of constraint.
>> All 12 people sending me pictures of Cleveland right
now in my discord. Stop project. And the second you gave everybody
universal suffrage, you put yourself at the mercy of people voting
voting in politicians and voting in priorities which will um
which those people will then go and amend the constitution how
they see fit. And like that's what you want. That's the status
quo. So if Christians utilize that for their own political purposes
in order to amend the constitution how they see fit, that's what
you people want, man. And so if you can't kind of speak out of
both sides of your mouth here and say, "Hey, I want uh somehow
the original >> that's like a reasonable point, but I also
think there are checks and balances to make sure that you don't
take away certain things, right?" So did you fake being sick?
>> Now you have motivation. Oh, I don't know. That's fine
for him saying that. I didn't fake being sick, though. I actually
did get sick. It sucked.
>> You know,
10 minutes. Um, it also up my sleep schedule. So, I'm waking
up like an hour before I should start stream and that's not enough
time for me to go figure stuff out.
I'm a slow riser.
>> Uh, somehow the original
um, you know, 10 amendments which or the Bill of Rights and say,
"Hey, I really really believe in those." Those were not meant
for universal suffrage, Connor. Those were not meant. None of
these original rights that you source were ever meant to have
a population
where everybody could vote. That's [__] crazy. Our
founders never envisioned that. They didn't envision women voting,
black people voting, and most men voting in under any capacity
did they ever envision this. And this this doesn't work. You
don't you can't have these sorts of rights if you have everybody
infranchised because they just vote to take them out whenever
they want. And part of the amendment process that you guys did
was you infranchised everybody and now you're you're all because
what ends up happening is it since you forced voting blocks for
special interests are now forming their own and they're taking
over the government and it really you guys off. But it's like
you did it to yourselves. You all did it. >> Yeah. His
mic is kind of I I find this funny because it's like
I this basically why I describe how I feel like democracy like
the United States democracy has kind of failed like we we figured
out that you can't have an informed
informed voter base or maybe it is just you know that's another
way of looking at it is like oh they are maybe they are informed
and they're just like actually we just don't want blacks and
browns and Muslims here anymore
and get them all out white Christian guys that's what we want
we're being a gay American empire. White Christian men only.
Okay, women get out to yourselves and then you come and you blame
us. You're like, "Well, wait a second. What about the Constitution?
You that up a long time ago, man. You guys [__] that
up a long long long time ago. The second you started mandating
universal section
is the living document. That's what they worked so hard for.
They didn't have to envision every form of possible future."
So, that is true and that is fine.
Then I guess if you have like these if you have like MAGA take
it over in some way. It probably
like you're probably just that's like a part of the dem democratic
system, right? Unfortunately Trump is like leaning into it hard.
You used to have presidents who wouldn't lean into it who would
lean out of it cuz they wanted the system to exist in the way
it did. But now you have a president who's l literally just leaning
into it and it's kind of [__] suffrage. You the constitution
right? It was never meant for that. It was meant for a population
of moral people and it was meant for people who had stake in
the nation, not for every [__] to just go and vote
their conscience. Right? The problem with that is you end up
with special interest groups who can then bribe voting blocks
and they carve pieces of the electorate out for themselves and
they carve pieces of the economy out for themselves. Right? there.
This whole idea of modern liberalism being in some way compatible
with how the Constitution was set up is [__] crazy.
You're arguing for a whole different type of universe than what
our founders envisioned. And if you're crazy enough to think
for a [__] second that our founders would have agreed
more with you than me, you're insane. They did not envision the
modern liberal project. And the reason that you guys keep running
back to the first amendment, even though you don't seem to understand
that that was a compromise as well, that came from the fact that
we had the Articles of Confederation and the states were concerned
that they would put one type of Protestantism above all other
types of Protestantism.
And what happened was they compromised
uh so that that wouldn't happen. And the states were allowed
to have their own
um religions inside the >> Is that in the federalist papers
by the way? the idea of the Protestantism elevating one over
the other. >> Is that there? >> Their perspective
states and they did and they were able to you could only vote
in fact if you were part of that religion. So >> seven
minutes you're okay everything you're saying is ahistorical I
guess. >> All right. Thank you guys very much for those
uh openers. So before we begin the open discussion
>> wait BB Poison does that work in a time where everything
is like documented
I think that works like
that works when you're talking about thousands of years ago.
Why would it work now?
>> I just want to let you guys know all you guys out there
watching that at the end after the uh hour back and forth, we're
going to have a Q&A. So, if you want have any questions for
uh either Andrew
>> I feel like does Andrew Wilson do this for the fossil
record? You might just look kind of silly assuming that. I I
don't know if that would be a you'd probably have to ask some
questions beforehand. You can maybe trap around that, but I don't
I don't think Andrew Wilson
he did on the Crucible. Oh, well that he's No way. There's no
way Wilson
There's no way he denies
Dino. Come on, >> Connor, uh send in a super chat and we'll
ask them at the end. So, um yeah. Um now with that said, let's
officially
>> Also, Connor, these are these are really good. These
like little Jack Daniels
>> They're del I know that they're like a chick drink,
but they're really good. >> What are they called? >> They're
called like uh Jack Daniels down home punch.
>> Yeah, they're it's such a chick fu thing, but uh they're
just delicious. But anyway, go ahead. >> Hey, if they go
down smooth and they get you hammered, it is what it is. Okay,
so number one, uh I have no problems going into uh history. Uh
if you want to ignore theology, we can. If you want to talk about
truth, uh, we we can. Uh, but what one of the things that I I
wanted to make sure that we nailed on since it's like Christian
nationalism is good, I guess, is like the positive statement
wi within this. Like >> this guy this guy is literally
just linking just drinking wine coolers
like
actual like my mom and her friends when I was like five when
they're like 30-year-old wine hags just drank wine coolers all
the time. This is Andrew Wilson. That's who he is. He's drinking
wine coolers, bro. >> Dynamic. Um, and you're right. It
is a status quo versus the non-status quo. >> So, I gave
my definition of Christian nationalism, which I think is necessarily
exclusive of Jews. I think it's necessarily exclusive of Hindus.
I think it's ne necessarily exclusive of seikhs or atheists or
whatever. And so, you're right that it's a tribal voting block
within the United States of America. But I'm not calling to end
that tribal voting block. I'm arguing about that voting block
getting so much power that they effectively institute a Christian
theocracy. That's against the liberal and libertarian project
of the United States of America. That's what I'm I'm advocating
against. >> I understand. I'm I mean, broadly, I don't
even think that your definition is too far off that we can't
just kind of go with it. Uh the only thing that I would put out
of it would be should that there's some sort of ought statement
that they must do that. I don't think that that is a
a proper Christian nationalism. Christian nationalism is just
Christianity
and saying that Christianity has every bit as much right to rule
as any other class does based on its own purpose and ethics.
And I think that's I think that that's a fine I think that's
thing too, isn't it? >> It it it really
is. I I don't When BPF argues for Christian nationalism, is he
arguing for
I think he's basically,
if I put stuff together, it seems like he's arguing for we can
do whatever whatever we can take this liberal project darling,
which is the United States political system. Whatever we can
take it and do, we have the right to do that as Christians, as
a voting block of Christians.
That that seems to be as far as he's going, right?
So, he's saying liberalism sucks and if we have to use liberalism
to beat liberalism, we'll do it. we're going to make our ideas
popular and then we're going to take over the government and
then we're going to get rid of liberalism because we don't like
it. >> Relatively is. But then we we kind of we need to
we need to drag it down though because so for instance like when
we're talking about Christianity uh we probably have like I don't
know a thousand sex and interpretations and we probably have
sub interpretation with within sex. >> Yeah. But you have
to say that about any political class. So MAGA has a thousand
different and then you could say that liberals have a thousand
different but it's the shared unification of value structures
in which you're fighting for. So could you would you agree with
me for instance that there's some unifications that Christians
have even if they have theological distinctions for instance
almost all Christians would be against abortion almost all Christians
would be
almost all Christians would be against X would be be against
Y would be 4X and 4 Y though there would be deviation within
you know particular churches or particular agendas they would
have some sort of shared unification like you do uh on the progressive
side you don't agree with progressive about all sorts of things,
but you agree enough with the things that they're talking about.
>> I was about to say, yeah, part part of the thing within
your opening argument that might not be the same as most of the
debates you take on this topic is I'm not a liberal maximist.
I I don't think liberty or freedom is like the sole virtue that
we should be prioritized with. I do care about other things and
I do think those other things the state has a role in promoting.
>> Yeah, I understand. But it is you are still promoting
the status quo and that >> correct. But but I wanted to
ask you, so for instance, like abortion, uh, Row versus Wade
was effectively legislated from the bench in what, like the 70s
or
>> Yeah. Well, I think Andrew did a good job of arguing
back against it, right? Lots of different There are like
It's not even Man, it's like what it's almost like in some ways
you could almost call
everybody a single issue voter. It's like what what's your big
issue within your voting block that you like collect into a voting
block on? And for I think the problem a lot of you know these
Christian nationalists or white nationalist types have is for
a long time they got told that you shouldn't organize based on
your identity. You should just pick the best like the the values
that match with you. And some people are getting together and
going okay actually if we just if we just get together as an
identity group we'll win every election. We can just do whatever
we want. And people are like no no don't do that. and they're
like, "Well, wait, these other groups do it. What's wrong with
that?"
I think that's kind of where Andrew is coming from with some
of the things is it's like Christianity is technically where
they overlap, but I don't even know like I'm sure a lot of Christians
wouldn't actually vote with Andrew Wilson or MAGA people. They'd
on principle either abstain or vote >> from the bench >> and
it got overturned from the bench. So that happened uh probably
because a substantial amount of Christians but also pro-life
people in general created a political coalition that got certain
peoples in power that overturn it. That all happened within the
liberal framework. So my my question is uh because you kind of
went on like okay yeah there's going to be certain things that
we all agree on though as >> Well that's not a liberal
what else do Christians believe needs to be instantiated in law?
>> Well like I would say anti-orn laws. I would say that
there would be decency laws. I would say that they would eliminate
marriage for instance. I think that they would get rid of it.
There's all sorts of >> Oh, you got to have you got to
have more than that. Andrew, what
uh what would you change if Christians got in? What would they
even put into law? Um they get rid of
Wait, you want to do an authoritarian take over the country cuz
you wanted banned? I mean, not even that I necessarily disagree
with that, but like isn't there a better way? We could go into
things that they would be unified for, but I don't even think
that you would disagree with that. Would >> There would
be some things like like so for instance like uh I'm a theist.
I'm not I'm not a Christian. So I don't believe in Christ. I
don't think he's the Messiah. I don't think that he's God instantiated.
But I do think he's probably uh one of the most important prophets
to ever walk the earth with like moral teachings that every single
human be
>> Hey, what who else believes this? Is this like a requirement
of being a liberal and
or some kind of liberal and like an influencer? Like you can't
be Christian. You got to have like some weird twist on it that
makes it like not
Can't you just be like Orthodox or Catholic or something? What's
the deal, bro? What's the deal? Is he a Muslim? He said he's
a deist. I don't even know what the that is. I'm a Christian,
but I don't believe Christ was was God. I don't believe Christ
what >> being should and could. >> Isn't that the
whole point of the book?
How do you take the whole point of the book and ignore it?
What what I actually would love to know like in terms of doctrine,
what the do you even
what even happens? How why does he Yeah, we could just read the
Wikipedia article. Sure.
>> Theism is
the philosophical position in rational theology that generally
rejects revelation as a source of divine knowledge. So he said
he's a deist, Christian deism. I'm assuming this is what he wants.
Well, he said he's not he's So, he's a deist, but he is some
sort of like um
>> what would you call it? Like Abrahamic deist, I would
assume, right?
>> No, no, no. It's Yeah. Yeah. I would I would assume
it's some sort of Abrahamicism that doesn't believe in Christ.
Yeah. Yeah. This is Christianity and deism
stemming from Christianity and theism can often refer to deists
who believe in the moral teachings but not the divinity of Jesus.
Okay.
>> this is just saying you're not a >> Why not just
say like the Bible has good moral story moral like moral teachings?
>> He said theist. No, he said. No, no, no. He said deist.
D E I S >> could learn from. Um, so when it comes to like
prohibitions on, we we don't have to fall into that as like an
argumentative trap, but like I wouldn't give I wouldn't give
two [__] about civil unions between a monogous couple.
I wouldn't give a [__] about that. >> That
was on the wrong mic. Does that sound a lot better now? >> It
does sound better.
>> Yeah, it does. [__] >> Yeah. Always
for you mod in the future if it sounds like they're on the wrong
mic. They probably are. So,
all right.
>> I don't know how the would Andrew show up and have the
worst audio ever and just this guy. Nobody said >> I'll
keep that in mind. I I I don't necessarily know if we want to
get into a debate about whether or not like is natural, but but
it's just the point. >> I don't think that that really
matters. The proposition the proposition here that matters ultimately
is a political
>> blame's the mod. I mean, it is the mod's fault unfortunately
or counterpoint's
I would hope that if somebody came on my stream or if I was on
their stream and I sounded like dog [__] they would
say, "Hey, you sound like dog [__] right now. Can
you fix your mic?" That's what I do. People come on my stream
and they sound like [__] Hey, you're really quiet.
Can you turn that up? Hey, you're really [__] up.
Your mic's [__] up. >> Proposition. What we're
arguing about here is political paradigms. The political paradigm
of the status quo versus the political paradigm of Christian
nationalism and what Christian nationalism is and wants for the
country. And if that's good, the thing is is that whether or
not it's true has no bearing really on anything ultimately because
whether or not there's any truth in the constitution and the
rights which you given have has no bearing. They're aiomatically
correct to the people who hold them and that's that. So we can
see this for instance when we have the declaration of independence
we see these axioms come out and what do they base the axioms
on God right the these are axiomatic rights which are given to
you we believe that these are based on God so without God this
God character there is no axiom from which to ground rights so
we have to agree that that's a starting position
so if if it go ahead >> real quick though I I don't yeah
let let me let me hit that real quick so I agree that uh rights
are pretty much only as good as you can enforce them, right?
So so freedom of conscience, freedom of speech, right to self-defense,
limited government in a constitution, that doesn't mean [__]
if you live in an authoritarian society. So it's only as true
as we believe them to be true. Uh however, I would say that we
can observe the way that authoritarian societies operate. We
can absorb we can observe the way in which they operate societies
operate. They operate fine. we can make a moral judgment on which
one we prefer. >> Yeah, I agree. I agree that you can make
uh judgments based around preferences for societies you wish
to live in. Um I'm not really so sure that this is not that the
progressive status quo isn't particularly authoritarian. I think
it is and I think we just have to look back to co to note if
you're thinking about a fascist dystopia, what are the things
you think of? They can come in and shut your business down whenever
they want to. They can make you wear statemandated clothing,
right? Which they did and called masks. They can make you have
travel papers so that you can go to and
the the mask thing is so stop being
okay. Um, in a fascist regime, they can make you wear clothing.
They made you wear masks. I agree it was authoritarian, but it's
like authoritarian with a purpose. There are emergency provisions
in a lot of democracies where people can do authoritarian things.
That's something you signed up for. That's something you're okay
with.
I I get it. It's calling it fascist is insane. Saying it's like
a fascist takeover is totally nuts. >> From work, which
they did, called co passports. And they can mandate uh things
which you do with your body from external uses like they did
with vaccines. They can also shut down your church whenever they
want for the interest of the public good. And that
>> all authoritarianism has a reason. Yes. But I'm saying
that this is built into the system of democracy that in certain
situations authoritarian orders can be issued
and you agree to that. That is that is something all of the people
who built the democracy that built like the US political system
agreed upon.
It's not it's literally not authoritarianism. It is a provision
of the system or at least it's not an authoritarian takeover.
It's not fascism.
There's no like ideological change in the country. And I don't
even know how you start to argue. Well, co was an excuse to do
that. That's just that's just hindsight being 2020. That's all
it is. I think they went way too far. For my personal opinion,
they went way too far with [__] Okay. Andrew's pointing
out it's not Christian. Okay. >> Uh things which you do
and shut your business down whenever they want to. They can make
you wear statemandated clothing, right? Which they did and >> that
like oh this is not just something that happen. They can make
you have travel papers so that you can go to and from work which
they did called co passports. And they can mandate uh things
which you do with your body from external uses like they did
with vaccines. They can also shut down your church whenever they
want for the interest of the public good. And the thing is is
like that sounds way more like a fascist dystopia than anything
I've heard Christian nationalists propose to be. >> Okay.
He is no he is arguing co provisions are fascism. Let's >> be
frank with you. On top of that, Connor, let's point this out.
That's the fascist dystopia,
okay? We lived in it. And it was all promoted by the status quo
leftists. And the thing that's really funny about this is like,
what is it that Christian nationalists are really proposing that
you're even against? The truth is is that >> I I don't
like that. So,
I agree it was an overreach and it was it was bad. It was like
really bad. I I think maybe not in the United States or Canada.
I remember seeing in Australia there was like actual protests
of people like getting
knocked down by the cops and it was pretty rough.
But I don't know like it it was temporary. I don't
I I feel like we can come away with that as a lesson just never
again. That's that's my take >> that you guys wanted universal
suffrage. The progressives wanted it in the worst way and they've
been fighting for it and they're still fighting right this second
in under the status quo to expand it. I've heard it even like
16-year-olds should be able to vote. That's a real thing. You
see it in Western Europe already. It was passed in in a couple
of countries there. And that's coming here. That's insane.
No. I mean, if anything, the age to vote should go up. Okay.
No, it does not need to go down past 18. I would say the age
the age to vote could go up, but then the age to like join the
military and a bunch of other things would have to go up with
it. for as long as you can like sign up for the military. It
feels like you should have that be the voting age
or >> too. They want to expand it to people who have been
disenfranchised because there were felons and all sorts of things
which should prohibit them from voting. If you give a stake to
every human being, Connor, right, then what's going to end up
happening is they're going to be able to vote out. >> Hold
on. I don't even think BPF believes this. I think he's like,
"This would be a good system." I like that it could be land owners
or people who have done public service.
So if you if you sign up for public service for some period of
time, then you g then you're
right? You take like some time to do public service where you're
compensated for it. It's like your job or something and then
afterwards you get discharged and you get like infranchised.
So you can own property or you can get infranchised through some
kind of public service is fine. >> And vote in rights meaning
things that they prefer whenever they feel like. >> Yeah.
No, I I realized that's what I was saying is like I didn't even
think just BPF doesn't believe in just land ownership. He believes
in the uh being able to buy him with public service. >> Well,
if your largest voting block is Christians, which it is, then
you're at the mercy of the thing you did, dude. You're at the
mercy of that. >> Yeah, of course. I I've never been an
advocate for direct democracy. That's re we're realistically
uh I'm I'm going to I'm going to work. >> That's not the
status quo. Then >> I'm You gave me a lot, so I want to
give some of it back. Okay. So, so I'm going to work in reverse
order. Okay. Um I in my ideal world of worlds, I would actually
make everybody take a citizenship test. Um I think you should
have to pass that in >> our troopers. Conor. Um >> yeah.
Yes. Unironically. Um and and if I if I could if I could >> Was
that a fascist government though, >> Actually, technic
>> I thought I thought that was the whole point of Starship
Troopers was is like a commentary on fascist government. It's
like a comedy,
>> isn't it? >> No. Yes, it was. But anyway, >> no,
not >> Oh, okay. Okay. Okay. Yeah, I thought I thought
that was the whole point. >> Are we talking about book
or movie, man? Because if you want to talk about fascism, number
one, I know Jim Teal pretty good. Number two, I know Starship
Troopers pretty good. >> Yeah. The whole critique was a
critique on fascism. It just ended up sounding so >> Paul
Hovind doesn't know what Paul Verhovven, the director of the
movie, he doesn't know what fascism is. So,
um with my
Connor type of guy who's going to say like well technically the
weren't fascists. Connor be like you're calling fascist and technically
that's not correct cuz they didn't follow like they didn't follow
Giovani Gentill's fascism directly and yeah
weren't very fascist. >> Yeah but in the books it also
looked very appealing honestly. >> Well yeah but the the
books were effectively I hate to say this but it was a minist
society. The private society was like libertarian with a tax
rate and you could do whatever you want within the private society,
but then the volunteer society was militarist where you had to
do a certain amount of uh service in order to gain the franch
>> and those were the ones who could vote, >> right?
Listen, man. Uh like I know that compared to the wignats, Chrisnats,
dissident right-wing people and Trump people, I'm to the left
of you guys, but I'm telling you, I don't claim conservative
arbitrarily. I don't claim
>> Well, I understand. I guess getting to the meat of it,
though. I'm not I'm I'm not making the claim that you're some
dude. I actually think Connor's fighting ghosts. Conor's argued
with Rob Noah, and Rob Nor consistently him with like the you
sweep for destiny. You're a total. You've betrayed everything
you stand for. And Andrew Wilson's just trying to have like a
normal conversation. He's actually being super polite, like way
more polite than I think he is to most people.
Fellow white man on the stream. He's like, "Yeah, let's let's
look at my fruity drink, brother." And and all all Conor hears
is like ghosts of all the other people who point out his >> Some
big leftist. I'm just saying, what is the actual proposition
here that we're quibbling over for Christian nationalism? If
it's the case that we're infranchised because progressives made
us infranchised and we can vote in or out whatever the we want.
>> You and you asked me a question to that point that I
want to answer. So you said, "What are Christian nationalists
advocating for that's more authoritarian than what people did
during CO?" And to give you a full answer on that, >> I
mean, the the answer here is just CO was bad. Nobody avows that.
It shouldn't have been done that way. Probably too much. We thought
we were all going to die and we shouldn't have been trying to
destroy people's lives over it. That was a mistake that was up.
It should be reversed. Should be fully reversed. Those people
should be apologized to. COVID
was largely a temporary measure. We don't have to wear the statemandated
clothing anymore. We don't have to present our vaccine passports.
We don't have to, you know, we don't have limited travel when
it comes to travel. All of that stuff was temporary. And by the
way, 1.1 million excess deaths did occur between 21.
>> Uh I can't describe the irony I feel knowing that the
German in chat says >> and 22. >> Put on the mask.
We don't have to get into the details, but if that fa that that's
a fatality rate effectively of like.3% of the United States population
even with all the restrictions, if we had the fatality of let's
say um Ebola, then I'm pretty sure that we would be having an
entirely different
>> It was I mean it we found out pretty quickly how not
fatalist like uh how not fatal it was.
It was wasn't almost immediately the concern wasn't fatalities
from it actually being fatal. It was overloading hospitals, right?
Not allow allowing treatment like that hospitals would in a be
in a constant state of triage. Very different
>> where we might even argue that those steps weren't far
enough if it was similarly violent to Ebola.
>> Yeah. But it wasn't. It wasn't. And you figured that
out very quickly that it wasn't as as lethal as Ebola, right?
That's why it wasn't that way. So for
>> uh let's be clear, CO three times the World War II deaths.
Yeah, but like how let's be real. How much time was it knocking
off? Like what were the excess deaths would be my question. Like
how much time was it really shaving off from other people, right?
Cuz I I I don't think I I think there's an argument that it really
a lot of people up and has [__] up lives the damage
economic
um social has been done to this day, right? And so like how much
time you just said 1.1 million in the United States. Okay. Like
I'm I'm curious how much time it shaved off of lives because
it seemed like almost everybody who died from CO was quite complicated
like or sorry had a lot of complications or at least that was
the overwhelming majority of people who were dying had like they
were old, they were fat, they were whatever. Right now there
were other cases where people got sick and they got up from COVID.
Sure. I agree. I just I think
I think the social damage the damage done to the social fabric
was a lot it was probably in excess of what should have been
done even to avoid the deaths >> for me like
>> yeah I know I know a lot of people died who are healthy
a lot of people die from pneumonia who are healthy a lot of people
die from the flu who are healthy I know >> uh uh >> but
I will say like there was just a happy medium that everybody
could have been fine with but it was like it was a part of like
a political time with Trump and stuff where everybody was at
each other's throats. Like you literally just could have worn
masks, you could have distanced, you could have not had full
lockdowns and I think everybody would have been fine. All it
took was like a little social cohesion and instead we took the
lack of social cohesion that was there in the first election
of Trump at the end of the first Trump term, I guess I should
say, and we like were at each other's throats completely. I swear
to God, I feel like personally
if
I really personally feel like if Trump wasn't the president,
co would not have been anywhere near as damaging to the social
fabric. Like people were so bullheaded on both sides. Unironically,
I'm going to both sides this one. People were so bullheaded on
both sides about everything.
It was
it was crazy. Obviously, I think conservatives are more in general,
but I think there was just like all it took was a tiny bit of
compromise and people could have been
during an e
Yeah, but do you see how that makes my point for me that the
point is is that based around based around joint >> both
sides co I'm sorry I I think the arguments from conservatives
were mostly but if you just took the actual not position of yeah
I'm willing to sacrifice a million granny's so that most people
can be fine so that kids can go to school you just took that
base position million granny's a million granny's will die okay
but my kids are going to go to school you just if you just do
that if you just say that like I'm fine with a ton of people
dying, then you're fine. That that's a totally normal position.
>> Point preference. We can easily restrict behaviors in
society that we don't find preferable
uh because society authoritarian societies society suffers because
of it. And so the thing >> that's true of society in general.
>> Well, the thing is though, Connor, is that if that's
the case when it comes >> Oh, also you should get the vaccine.
Sorry. you you have you had like three to six months to say I
don't want the vaccine I don't know if it's going to work and
then basically it was like okay you can get the vaccine that's
I after that point like just get the vaccine >> to universal
suffrage and that's a demand which is made you can't then get
upset because one of the voting blocks happens to be the largest
is Christian and they're going to push their agenda >> being
fine with a million people no I'm sorry I think the the thriving
the society is about
making sure I think there's more harm done to to the society
by keeping people inside, keeping kids inside, not letting them
go to school, doing it remotely. These are more harm to the society
than just granny's dying. I understand that's like an opinion
and I'm I'm not even really here to argue it. I get that that
like seems like frustrating to people. I think that's the way
it is. Sorry. >> Agenda through. >> If anything,
get get all the old people, put them in homes together, and then
lock those homes down,
deliver their groceries to them, take care of them that way.
>> You did it to yourselves. So, how do you I don't know
how you reconcile that position because because we're there's
two there's two games. >> I'll say I'm speaking in retrospect.
I genuinely don't have that much problem with how governments
handled it for the most part because I think there's so much
uncertainty. I don't have like a lot of concern for other people
or sorry for other proposals and other ideas that happen to win
out. Like I don't think I'm correct
totally
right. I I don't think I'm correct. I'm just saying that's my
opinion. I don't like I don't hate or totally
deny the humanity of people who wanted full lockdowns. I think
it's like fine. I think this is a respectable position. Okay?
Because I do not presume that you are a Christian nationalist
who wants to take
secularists, liberals,
atheists,
uh Christians, moderate Christians. You probably don't want them
to create a tribal group that beats you at the at the state game.
You want to win. You want to win. You want to impose a Christian
national power. Yes. For >> What I'm trying to argue is
that you should not want to destroy the entire game of constitutionalism,
Republicanism
>> But Connor, this is a counterintuitive point. So you
can't make >> I'll show you. You can't make the point.
>> BPF's argument is going to be living document. We can
make changes that we can make. Um, if we make the changes within
the rules, if we're not just like straight up, you know, if it's
not a total fascist takeover like a military coup or something,
a juna,
it's not that, then
what can you complain about? If we just use liberalism to defeat
liberalism, what's the problem? I >> mean, think about
how circular this is. Everybody should be infranchised,
but we know if everybody's infranchised that they're going to
create interest blocks. when they create interest blocks, the
only way that you can actually have power is through I >> Are
we presenting that if it's just restricted to land owners, those
people don't form interest blocks? Why does this problem go away
if you restrict it down to just land owners?
What if you just restricted it to white Christian land owners?
Would those people not immediately form interest blocks that
compete with each other?
I don't Why does this problem disappear would be my question.
What part of cutting it down to just this group makes that problem
Or are you saying that you as long as like a white man is winning
out in the society, you're fine. Just get the out. As long as
it's not a winning, I'm fine. If if the white man who wants me
dead wins, that's fine. At least it's a white man who killed
me. No more no more dominance. Okay. >> True. Joint interest
blocks. You yourself as a voter have no power at all. You as
a collective voter have a lot of power. Okay. Right. Arguing.
>> Hang on a second. Let me just finish the circularity
of the argument. If that's the case, >> Andrew has to accept
as a correlary of this that if white people, if like white Christians
decide to try to take things over, they institute bad policies
and then they're thoroughly rejected by the society and there
are like persecutions that happen after that's probably an understandable
and predictable consequence of trying to do a take over the government
and trying to like take rights away the rights away from other
groups, right? I would imagine you'd have to accept that coralary,
right? Oh, if we fail, we're >> When you say, "Well, Christians
are forming this block in order to maintain power before somebody
else forms a block and maintains power." Uh, then I don't know
what you're arguing. Of course, we're going to do that. If we
don't do that, Connor, then Marxists will do it. Leftists will
do it. People like this will do it. And they don't have our best
interest in mind. >> Why is Andrew pretending that the
blocks are all ideological?
He's not normally one to get Just say it, Andrew.
The blocks. The Indians.
They'll form a block. Say it. Say it. This is a crazy world view.
Uh,
no. It's like a Mchuavevelian worldview. If you believe if you
believe in like great power politics. Oh, what's the word? There's
like a name for this. Take. What is it? What is it like? Um,
when you only believe in in power like might makes right as a
political worldview. What is that called again? I forget the
name. It's not just great power politics. There's like a name.
Realism. Yeah, realism. Isn't this just like like electoral realism?
I've noticed that everybody forms blocks. The reason white people
have been like have been sort of lobbied against in some ways
that the DEI stuff has taken over is because other people form
blocks on their identity on their like ethnicity
and us not doing it is us. It's like it's like making us lose.
Why don't we just start forming blocks on our our on our identity,
on our religion, on our ethnicity? Although I'd argue Christians
were already a voting block anyway, or at least evangelicals,
evangelicals were already a voting block. But that that's the
argument, right? People were already doing this and by not participating,
you just agree to lose. I don't think this like a crazy worldview.
It's just not like a very morally like doing what's right. It's
not informed by doing what's right. >> Fine, dude. So what
choice do we have but to form a block and pass our agenda now
when weinging do it? What choice? >> Okay. So what what
I would >> uh that is an interesting point. It's like hey
I feel like we're seeing concerning things crop up that are like
anti-white. We're seeing anti-white sentiment crop up. Why shouldn't
white people like join as a group right now and take over and
change things before they're not a group that can take over?
That's I don't know. That's like an interesting thing. It's a
an interesting question to posit.
>> Uh the problem with realism is you're not supposed to
have moral prescriptions and Andrew has so many of those. Well,
no. It's saying that you shouldn't have your moral prescriptions
over you. Your moral prescriptions shouldn't cloud what you think
is actually going to happen, right? He's saying we should we
should seize power totally to enforce our moral
without concern over whether or not we'll maintain power. like
we will use the power we have now and we won't be concerned about
whether we'll maintain power. We'll just use our power now to
enforce our moral prescriptions. I think that's more where he's
going. That's why I asked like what does he what happens if you
lose here? Cuz to me it sounds like you're just you're ready
and willing to get totally if you lose like you will you will
be that that will just >> Say is I also hate leftists and
probably hate them for the same reason. I also hate fascists.
I also hate for them for the same reason. And when it comes to
Christian nationalists, if you're just talking about u a political
alignment of people of shared values who advocate within the
republic for their own legislation, that's all we've ever been
doing for 250 years.
>> You're missing a point. You're missing a critical point.
>> No, I'm not missing the point. And by the way, I'm sorry
you just keep interrupting me, so I want to continue for a little
bit. All right, go ahead. >> Okay. We've been you you're
saying that Oh, well, we create special interest groups that
then advocate for policy. Dude, the way the way now that I can
see it, the way Rob Noir and Andrew Wilson argue is like so different.
It's like so
>> Um, yeah, Rob Nor and Counterpoints are like the same.
They interrupt the other person and complain about interrupting
a lot. I'm not sure I've ever seen them legitimately go, "Oh,
you know what? I am interrupting you. I'm sorry. That's my bad.
Go ahead." >> Andrew is just like, "Yeah, you go ahead.
Okay, I'll let you talk." That's very funny to me.
>> That's just been true. That's just been true. How is
this any different?
It wasn't true 19th century or the early 20th century or the
mid 20th century or the late 20th century. It wasn't true pre
the two part >> although I will say
the part where Andrew is saying Christians didn't organize his
blocks before this that doesn't ring true to me at all if he
if he wanted to you know go back to being BPF the guy who was
arguing in favor of little Timmy
that I think he he's cooking with gas a little bit because it
is about ethnicity like white people don't organize as a block
and they haven't before like basically co
>> but I don't know he's he keeps saying like Christians,
Christian nationalism.
It to me it's just very funny that I'd say people have
it would be weird to just argue he's like a white nationalist
trying to use Christian as a as like a dog whistle, but he's
I feel like he is
>> I don't know. He's like a Tucker nationalist. Okay,
you start calling these people Tucker nationalists. They're like
using Christian as a code word. Okay. It's like coded language
for
>> I I don't know how else to look at it, right? Because
they they'll never say we're white nationalists, but then people
will ask them about identity and they'll go, "Yeah, like I'm
proud to be white. I I think white people should be able to organize
and have like their rights and be a block of voters." Yeah, whites.
I think I think maintaining like, you know, the what is it? They
call them heritage Americans or
Foundational Americans. They've got it like you know how they
call you know how true logic calls black people basketball Americans
for whites they started calling them like heritage Americans
foundational Americans
>> I don't know >> party system is an emergence which
happened from universal suffrage there was no two-party system
before that okay that's an emergent property of a of uh universal
suffrage because why >> the two parties are made up of
a series of special interest groups who have aligned into the
two parties >> but let me explain why why That is the case.
It's the case because of a consolidation of power. The idea here
is
>> hold on that that's what I'm saying. Porter Beller,
uh, he's always talked about it. I think he said he's gotten
close to using it in like more coded ways, but he was still on
Fox News. Like he would say like, "Yeah, it's definitely okay
to be white. Why would that upset people?" He does like a lot
of the coded stuff and he's gotten way more overt now. But he
would never call himself a white nationalist, right? Even though
that's probably what he's trying to hint at doing. like he wants
a white nationalist project. And that doesn't mean he wants like
blacks killed. He doesn't want browns.
>> He probably just wants white people to vote as an interest
group and
probably get rid of some suffrage. Some pass some very white
advantage legislation about who gets to vote and [__]
If we're going to have voting blocks, then we want to have uh
power, right? And the only way to have power is in numbers. So
if you have one that's adverse to the other, we have a block
that's large enough that we can actually maintain some sort of
power. The problem that comes in here is if Christians don't
have authority and power and they're able to maintain authority
and power by changing the constitution to suit them so that they're
not out of power, then Marxist and others will come in and when
they have power, change the rule so that they never lose it.
So the question here is it's we're all running for the finish
line here. The question is who gets there first? Yeah. >> Okay.
I I'm going to say that that's an acknowledgement of if you fail,
you know, you're okay. I think that that is a natural correlary
of what Andrew just said. That is acknowledging, yeah, if we
fail now and we fall out of the majority, we become a minority,
like a significant minority, we're like a lot smaller, we're
we're probably just >> Okay, hang on. Is it going to be
Christian number all of the groups that you're talking about
by a factor of 10? >> I don't think that that's correct.
And let me give you a demonstration for why I don't think that
that's correct. I think that what you see is you see coalitions
now forming based around the idea of not just ethnos. Now you
remember when ethnos was the thing that coalitions were trying
to kind of uh bring up. Now that the reason that was a terrible
plan uh is because if you just base it on ethnos, you don't have
the numbers inside the United States and you haven't for a long
time. Maybe you could have pulled that off, you know, uh when
it was 95% white. um you know 70 years ago, 80 years ago, something
like that. But that's no longer the case. Whites are 60% and
white women vote against uh white men anyway. >> Sorry.
Uh that's actually really funny though. You just knew that was
going to be Andrew's position in some way. It's like listen,
we we could just call ourselves white nationalists, but white
women have ruined it for everybody
>> unless they're married. Uh so now the coalition is generally
under religion or some other political faculty but religion takes
the priority because it's still a shared value. So me and Hispanic
people have this shared value. Me and Chinese people have this
shared
>> does a good job of explaining why the gropers are the
gropers, right? Why you can have like the most mixed race goblin
child in New York City talking to Sneo with an America first
hat on. Okay,
it explains a lot. We all have this shared value because of that.
That does create and form a very powerful voting block. If we
get in and we don't change it so that we don't have mass migration
and so that we can't keep Christianity as the most powerful voting
block, other voting blocks will form under Marxism. Hang on.
They will form under Marxism and they will do it >> there.
Okay. But here's here's a contradiction and also I want to know
your definition of Marxism in a second. So number one, uh I I
would say that the contradiction in what you just said is that
90 to 99% of the mass immigration coming to the United States
is from South and Central America. They are infinitely more Christian
and infinitely more socially conservative than Americans are.
Now moving to the economics, you're saying, "Oh, well they're
uh you know, maybe they're more economically redistributed."
>> Oh god.
Uh this is the one time I've seen Andrew. Not the one time Andrew
does things like when he said landlocked earlier when you use
landlocked totally incorrectly. Andrew is not like classically
educated. He he makes mistakes at times and he it's not just
in in terms but he makes mistakes in concepts. He is very like
preparation oriented. He builds up his like logic trees. He tests
them out in a lot of debates and he he grinds up to being a really
good debater. Right. But one of the times I've seen him look
like a total [__] was when he argued that obviously
all wages would go up if you cut women out of the workforce was
like one of the most economically illiterate opinions I've ever
seen in my entire life is very very funny. Okay. Um at least
in terms of classical economics going back a long time. We're
entering like humans need not apply territory where maybe something
like that starts to become true or is the way we're going. But
we're not there yet. Okay.
totally ignoring the concept of economies of scale. He probably
never even heard of economies of scale before. It was very very
very funny. I wonder if he'll go in a similar direction here.
>> Well, I would say that Christian nationalists as a block
with you being representative of maybe the Ortho sect and Nick
Fuentes being representative of the trads or whatever, the trads
are infinitely more interested in redistributive economics. And
so when you say Marxism,
uh what what do you mean? Because I don't see Donald Trump who
was picked as the guy who could be the vanguard.
>> Is Connor like unfamiliar with a lot of the redistributive
policies of third
>> Like I I feel like he's got to understand that, right?
That that that would like fall under duties. like part of part
of Marxism like the you know to each by their need from each
based on their ability based on their whatever the whatever the
phrase is that's like legitimately just Christian belief Christian
doctrine no that's just like being a good person
so it's described in a secular way in Marxism Christian nationalists
would believe in that absolutely the [__] are we
talking from each according to their ability to each according
to their need or something like that yeah that's that would totally
be a Christian doctrine for the far rightwing.
>> He's currently embracing Mandani and they both got into
power through economic populism. So, so how is Christian nationalism
going to guard against number one economic populism? Number two,
how are you defining >> Well, first e the economic populism
uh of New York, not of the nation. That's one. But let's dive
into this so that there's a couple of different points to address.
Uh Marxism is the movement towards the people having control
of ownership, right? All private ownership being abolished. That's
what Marxism is. If you're talking about socialism, that's the
idea that the state has control over all private ownership. Okay?
That's the Now, we've never been able to get from socialism to
real Marxism. It's always stopped at the socialism level. But
in order for the state to hold all private equity and private
ownership, which is what they want to do, Marxists want to do
ultimately, they need to have power in order to control the state.
That's what they have to have. So they are going to do this,
Connor, whether you like it or not. They've done it and done
it and done it and done it and done it. And they're doing it
right now in New York. They're trying. I mean, that's what that's
what [__] Marxists do when you're talking about importing
people from South America. Dude, what
>> you still also have to have other shared cultural values.
And it is true that by the second or third generation, they begin
to have those, which is why they're starting to break for the
right instead of the left. But the left doesn't want to just
flood us with South Americans anymore. They're looking elsewhere.
And so the thing is is like, look, ultimately,
the Latinos were bad enough, but now they want to bring in Indians.
And that's where we have to draw the There is a shared voting
block here and the shared voting block is Christian values and
Christian ethics and if it's the case that we can control power
so that we can keep other people out um and our voting block
is assured to be in the power position for the social order of
society.
That's good because otherwise some [__] buddy else
will. Now, even if you disagree with me on mass migration or
you disagree with me on immigration policy or you disagree with
me on economics or things like that, you're not going to be able
to disagree with me on power distribution. Marxist want it. >> I
don't. >> Yeah. Marxist [__] Hang on a minute.
Marxists want it. Progressives want it. Leftists want it. They
all want it. And by the way, when they get it, they're going
to try to maintain it. And if that means that they got to change
laws to do it, they'll do that, too. So, it's a race to the finish
line. And man, I really want us to win. Okay, I I appreciate
what you said, but what I would say is liberals and libertarians
and Republicans, by the way, people who believe in a republic,
people who believe in the con
ordered law and order
for a few minutes, so I'd like an opportunity to speak, please.
>> Yeah. Yeah, that's fair. >> So, um, so people
who actually believe in the >> Again, he's like, you're
right. I was interrupting you. My bad. >> Feel like I do
this, so I appreciate Andrew doing it a little bit. Okay. I'm
like, you know what? I am being an my >> Republic of the
United States for which it stands and all the all the that we
get taught as children. >> They want to perpetuate the
game as we currently have it which means keeping the first amendment
which is freedom of conscience, freedom of speech. The second
amendment which is the right to keep and bear arms up to and
including against the tyrannical government. It's like the fourth,
fifth and eth amendment and the 14th amendment which are basically
due due process laws. And so they want to keep all of that. So
when you're talking about and I would say a majority of the population,
you have to bear in mind a third of the population votes left,
a third of the population votes right, and a third of the country
doesn't vote at all. And also even within the Christian block,
which you keep mentioning, is the largest demographic within
the United States. Let's be real, 30 to 35% of the country is
secular or atheist, meaning that they actually don't believe
in God at all. And then the 70% of the Christians, probably,
let's say half of them to probably 80% of them are
Christians. And what I mean by that is they don't take their
faith seriously. They don't think about God. They don't think
about Jesus. They don't think about heaven. They don't think
about divinity. They just go on Easter and Christmas. And so
what I'm saying is I have no resentments towards you trying to
build a a Christian political advocacy block. What I'm saying
is that civic nationalism
covers all of those people and civic nationalism only involves
the proposition that you believe in the Constitution of the United
States.
Yeah, it's a really tough story to tell, though. It's not quite
the same. The roots don't go quite as deep.
People try to do that. Bannon's been trying to do that. Okay.
It just turns out that when you go away from civic nationalism,
all the things that civ civic nationalism touches on in the brain,
all of the things it touches in like the amydala, like all of
the primal parts of your brain, those same parts all get touched.
Okay? Not in a not in a weird way. They all get like tapped on
in the in a way more powerful way if you make it about race or
about religion. Unfortunately, people just don't care about their
country as much as they care about their race or religion
by and large. Okay,
it turns out that actually being racist seems to be popular.
That when you make it like racial race uh like race-based existentialism,
that works. We make it on religious based existentialis existentialism.
It also works. Helps that we're in a society where people are
like directionless. Feels like Christianity does that, you know,
gives direction to people a lot better. So if to FNAP pipeline
is undefeated. Uh
yeah, I mean it kind of is. I thought civic nationalism was good.
I've sort of moved away from populism in general. I'm like I
think liberalism is going to lose, but I'm just seeing that like
unfortunately you want you want somebody. Okay. you all you want
is like a true
civic nationalist who believes all of those things and then eventually
you realize that there isn't a true civic nationalist who believes
all of those things and just wants your country to be successful
no matter color or creed. Those people don't exist. It's just
all a whole bunch of different racists who are who are going
to grift when they get in in any form of power. They're just
going to start running crypto scams or
like it that's it. >> That's it. I've been considering
stalism, dude. I don't know. I I'm
politics feels pretty pretty rough right now. I'm not going to
lie. >> It's a far lower bar to entry.
>> Yeah. So, again, these things are are are contradictory
in their own right. First, we don't have a I'll tell you first,
we don't have a republic. A
>> Andrew does this, okay? He's like, "Okay, I won't interrupt
you." And that all Andrew's been thinking about is why his point
was really critical and that if Connor had let him interrupt,
they could have saved a bunch of time. It's like he's going to
train Connor to know that that's what had just happened. You
interrupted me when I was interrupting you and you need to know
that if I if you had let me interrupt, I could have saved us
a bunch of time. So now he's going to have to yap on on Oh, we
don't have a republic. There is no republic. >> If you
have everybody in franchise, that's no longer a republic. Okay,
>> we vote for representatives. >> Yeah, but we never
were supposed to. >> No, no, no. >> We never were
supposed to ever.
>> Well, no. I thought I thought people were supposed to
vote for representatives. They just weren't supposed to be everybody
voting. >> Excuse me, but black men getting the vote, I'm
just going to see as a moral good. Women getting the vote, we
could argue about. I don't really care. But the point is that
>> I I wish Connor just for the optics of
Just ask which one was the worst. I mean, it's we know it's women's
suffrage. He should have just asked, right? He should have just
said like, "Do you think black people getting the vote was bad?"
>> Like, we still choose representatives. the average
>> Okay, that's >> we supposed to ever. >> Excuse
me, but black men getting the vote, I'm just going to see as
a moral good. Women getting the vote, we could argue about. I
don't really >> Oh, I see. Yeah, we could argue about Oh,
I see. I missed it when I was talking about what I was concerned
about. I wish you would have just asked which why do you think
black people getting the vote was bad?
>> Oh, black men getting the vote. >> But the point
is that like we still choose representatives. The average citizen
does not write legis.
>> This is why Connor's wife controls none of the finances.
Okay? He doesn't believe in women's suffrage. He doesn't believe
in women's right to self-determination. Okay? Connor doesn't
believe in any of those things. >> Two ever select representatives.
Connor,
>> that that really makes a lot of his decisions make sense
>> when you think about it.
>> Wait. No. >> We started as a representative republic.
What the [__] are you talking about? Listen to me.
You I I maybe you just have no idea. How do you think the president
used to get elected? Do you think that the people got to vote
on
>> No.
Exactly. No. >> Wait. Who?
The people didn't get to vote on anything except their state
reps. The
>> Okay. I want to talk about how Conor's dumb here, but
he literally is just arguing that you always elected representatives
and how Andrew is making this like face and mocking voice. Did
he just not hear? The face and mocking voice seems really unnecessary
and weird
when you are just restating their point but saying no first.
No.
state reps were the ones who then sent the federal reps up and
only certain people inside of the states were able to vote at
all and most of the requirements were that they were Christians
because what you had to be of good moral standing they didn't
want >> think you contradicted me at all >> hang
on they didn't want people who were in bad moral standing the
second you picked the president in the 19 >> I didn't interrupt
you I let you go can I finish
>> so the thing is man is that the big
>> Andrew just thinks Connor is arguing that universal
suffrage is required for a republic and it's not >> problem
that you have. >> He's not even right about how we voted
originally. It doesn't matter. Universal suff suffrage is unrelated
to a representative republic or borderline unrelated. They're
like um
they're like orthogonal concepts. >> The contradictory
nature of what it is that you're stating is you start with first
with a presupposition which is false that we still have a republic.
We don't the re we now are moving towards direct democracy
and that's probably what we're going to see in our lifetime or
something more akin to it. That's the ever expansive flow is
towards that not a republic when you're talking about checks
and balances and things like this. This has been out the door
for a long time because now the public can vote directly on issues
and so they can be bribed. The whole system's he
>> okay like this is true. This is Hold on. It's true,
but all of the words he like doesn't know the words.
>> He He doesn't know the words. He just doesn't know the
words. He's saying something that's true. Principally, the public
can be bribed. That is a problem of like a fully um what do you
call it? Like a a fully infranchised populace, right? That you
can basically just make promises to certain blocks to get them
in your on your side. But he's calling it direct democracy. He
doesn't know that that's a word that means something. He's using
he's it's the ladlock problem again. Okay. He's just saying weird
things. This is Andrew got really good at the arguments around
gender and and you know patriarchy and stuff and he has not been
polishing these these arguments off at all. I don't know. This
is rough. >> Done. The republic has already fallen. That's
not even here anymore. The original uh statement of our founders
for what a republic was which was based on a compromise due to
the fact we had the articles of confederation and that was a
mess. It was a mess. We couldn't we couldn't govern anything.
Okay, the Republic is dead. I don't know where you've been. Now
it's a Zurich rush to power based on the infranchisement of people
and that now that people have realized that you can collectivize
uh through infranchisement to seize power, it's a matter of who
gets there first and who's willing to change the laws when they
are there, Connor. And the thing is is that if we don't do it,
they're going to [__] do it to us. So I don't I don't
even understand the proposition that you're giving here. You
already know that that's true. You know, if Christians don't
rush to do it, others will. And by the way, when you talk about
secularists here, a lot of secularists are voting the way that
Christians vote now because they're sick of social morbid degeneracy
and still see Christian ethics as being superior to the alternative
of progressive degeneracy. So again and again and again telling
me that we can't have a voting block when we've already had tons
of successful elections based on the emergent political party
of Christian nationalism or Christian populism. I don't know
what the [__] you're talking about cuz we seem like
we're kicking the [__] out of everybody. Connor.
>> Okay, I'm going to try to be very specific because I'm
not sure if you heard me before. So I'm going to say it
Uh Connor, uh I think BPF has like a an argument for there's
like a solid argument for if you just think about outcomes that
like they are adopting the correct strategy and they're winning
and argue why we shouldn't do that because other people have
done this. We were losing for a long time and and now we are
working as a group and we're winning and [__] you.
Doesn't matter that we're lying. Doesn't matter that we're full
of [__] Doesn't matter that we don't care about the
values of the country. We're winning. [__] you. And
I I don't think Connor is going to engage with that. He's probably
gonna go back and engage with Andrew not understanding what a
direct democracy is. >> I don't care that Christian conservatives
with aligned values
vote in their conscience. I I I don't I don't give too what I
actually wouldn't even care.
I wouldn't even care if they got a healthy chunk of what they
wanted. I'm a dude. I don't need an abortion. Okay? I'm not black.
Maybe uh you know what whatever you want to do with black folk.
not you, but Nick or whatever, right? Like I I don't This isn't
skin off of my ass. What I'm saying is that the liberal libertarian
Republican project that the United States is is not dead. And
I don't concede that and I don't agree with you. We vote for
representatives. There is not a single person in the state of
Florida who has ever >> It's just the Republic's not dead.
To be fair, there's a stupid thing Andrew said. probably should
try to crucify >> crafted a piece of legislation that has
gone through either house of Congress. It hasn't happened except
for the elected representatives.
The only thing that we vote on the only thing that we voted on
in the state of Florida is we voted on state level memorandums
that had to reach a certain a certain threshold to even
>> [__] certain a certain level a certain level
of memorandums
>> be considered by the state. I'm sorry. What piece of
federal legislation have I cap people voting on in the past?
>> Well, no, no, no. It's not it's not the capability of
voting, but drafting. >> Well, then it's not direct democracy.
What are you talking about? >> Private citizens are actually
the ones who draft almost all federal legislation who are part
of think tanks. Those think tanks then bribe the electorate and
they pass through NOS's to the representatives things in which
to vote on. So, the thing is, >> the republic works. Do
you do do you think a representative crafts everything from scratch?
Well, I mean, originally there I do think that they had assistance,
but generally this were from property owners or stakeholders.
Stakeholders had a lot more to lose inside of a of the republic
than the average citizen does. The average >> complaints,
bro. Can you let me finish the point? >> Absolutely. It
is the case.
>> Um, he's doing this, but I don't believe it's intentional,
Ry. it like he he would I don't think it's intentional cuz he
would just be humiliating himself if he got into an argument
over the definition and both people are like we have to go look
it up now right that's the thing is like you don't you don't
actually win by misusing terms you kind of just get laughed at
>> and then you have to go well talk about the concept
I'm talking about and realistically it doesn't change much you
just get laughed at it's just would be embarrassing but it's
weird that Connor's not pulling it out that he doesn't know it
>> is that if you have a perpetual underclass that you
want to appeal to even though all of the things have been taken
care of. >> Um I think Porter Bellar it's like it's something
like okay not everybody's represented the same way because for
certain groups to get certain bills to pass or whatever they
might think okay like we're Republicans. We need to make sure
this bill serves people who will vote for us again and we don't
really need to worry about any worry about anybody else. We don't
need to make it serve Americans. So we're going to like pass
this bill. we're going to include some funding that helps like
this community out, that community out, and there are people
you could just leave out entirely, right? Like maybe it's something
like that. It's not just, you know, making sure everybody's okay.
But then again, I don't know if that's even different than what
would happen if you didn't have NGOs's helping
to be honest with you. So again, it's just like what's the difference
from before it's
I thought the whole point with like Bretton Woods was that was
written by bankers anyway, right?
>> Am I crazy?
like incorporating the Federal Reserve.
>> I thought that was the whole point of
>> whatever forum, you know, food >> used to just
have industry leaders who would help out with legislation all
the time, right? >> Hunger, water, basic needs, they're
basically a thing of the past, at least here in the United States.
It's true that people have economic hard times, but the idea
that we just have people starving everywhere or can't get access
to to clean water is insane. We've defeated most of these problems
by and large. What happens though is that there's a consistent
appeal to the underclass. As people get richer, the people on
the bottom end of the get-rich, uh they're appealed to by another
form of the electorate to say, "Hey, these guys over here are
really [__] you. So, you need a form of block so
that you can pull their resources down." Now, that was never
the intention of the republic. Now, the electorate can be bribed.
And because the elector can be bribed and they can vote their
own bribe money to themselves.
Okay. The republic is f >> God. We should start watching
uh [__] What is it? I watched something on this.
Is it just rules for rulers?
This is like the argument that
basically Yeah. The public public is just going to take the treasury
and rate it whenever they want. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. This is rules
for rulers. I we should watch that video. To be honest, I'm thinking
about we got an hour left.
We might watch like another 30 minutes of this and then cap it
off with rules for rulers because I I've seen it referenced a
couple times in stuff we've watched over the past week in >> maybe
more than a week, past month maybe. It's just a good refresher
once in a while to see I think it's like a very it does just
does a very good job of of explaining how power works in political
systems. I'm talking about the CGP gray video. I think there's
a book as well. >> It is crushed. There is no safeguard
from this. None. And so now it's just a rush to power, bro. That's
it.
>> Uh I mean I I think you're just describing societies,
but >> that's not how societies are supposed to work. You're
not supposed to be able to form a voting block to vote yourself
other people's money. That's crazy. >> So So you think
in medieval Europe, you've appealed to history and you've said
that said that my analysis ahistorical, which I don't agree with.
But you think that in medieval history, it wasn't
>> that that's different. That's also transparent. The
thing about medieval history is people understood the rules.
If you got more knives than me, you got more people more knives
than me, you get to take my them's the rules and there's no confusion
about the rules. Okay, maybe you could say there's confusion
in that you think you have protection from a lord or something.
But in this system, it's like supposed to be everybody represented
and taken care of, right? Like you you put you pay your taxes
and the government takes care of you. And those aren't really
the rules is probably what Andrew is going to argue. But the
the transparency of like a feudal system is is very different.
like uh interest blocks for >> but you're you are transparently
in that case which is a little different >> forming power
blocks and then advocated to the top level in order to get to
the you don't think feudal lords were who made power like power
plays in medieval >> that's a different problem you talking
about let me explain in in the feudal system and you can find
this in both Japan and Europe because they followed a similar
type of feudalism it wasn't quite a cast system but it was a
nobility class versus a non-nobility class. The nobles had all
the stake. Knights held the land or samuris held the land. The
knights of uh you know Japan uh they were reporting to damios
who were family leaders. Okay. In this case, they were reporting
to
I want to hear how Andrew talks about this. I I think I told
you guys I talked to Beckett
like a couple nights ago and for some reason the conversation
changed onto this and he started telling me about how basically
like the black death caused democracy to come about in Europe.
like the the the foundations of democracy stem from the black
death in Europe. This is a very interesting conversation. We'll
see if Andrew goes anywhere near that >> to either Yles
or Vic counts or whatever depending on where you were in Europe.
They were the ones who were collecting the duties on the land
and that would get sent over to the king or to a prince or to
some other middle manager all the way up. The truth is is that
only those people were allowed to have a say because they were
the only people who had a stake. The peasants were living at
their behest. You you did not refute that there were power blocks.
All you did was describe them.
>> The peasants couldn't vote themselves the knights money,
dude. >> Yeah, but the peasants had to remain industrious
in order for their lords to have the ties and the arms have to
be and all that kind of stuff in order to be politically relevant.
You're basically acting like politics was invented in the 20th
century. >> No, I'm just telling I'm trying to explain
to you how power blocks you
work.
being polite because I like it when you y infranchise. >> You
didn't need to explain those things. >> Yeah, but but Connor,
I think I do because when you're talking about infranchising
a peasant class, would would medieval Europe have worked if peasants
could vote themselves the night's land?
>> Probably not. >> No. And this republic isn't going
to work because that's what they're doing.
>> Number one. Number one. Okay. That's I that's what I
first asked Tick and is basically um is basically like don't
interest blocks just form anyway and then you could have taxes
that go on different industries and stuff and the interest blocks
could form could basically vote to over other industries. I don't
know what changes what about anything changes in terms of interest
blocks forming and them competing against each other. I you've
just reduced the number of people who can form an interest block
but you've not really changed the core concept that in that system
interest blocks win. forming the largest interest block means
you win. Yeah, I I vote to take their land. >> I don't
agree with you descriptively at all. So, I'll just go into that.
So, the chief complaint from the left, by the way, not necessarily
me, is that the current legislative system is captured by billionaires,
energy companies, military-industrial complex folks, tech. Oh,
this was the whole thing. charging gem was um apparently when
the black death happened suddenly the lords couldn't exercise
as much power over the peasants because basically you only had
you barely you you had enough peasants to farm everything before
and probably have enough time for people to be pretty relaxed
and then the black death came along and killed a ton of people
and so you needed every peasant to farm the land and basically
people would be like hey well if you come on my farm peasant
hey peasant if you come over to my farm I'll give you a little
money I'll give you a little bit of the harvest I'll give you
a little bit of this a little bit of And then they realized they
had bargaining power because there was not enough labor, right?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Oh, Stalin sloth breaking in with the exact same point. Yeah.
Yeah. Feudalism, uh,
it wouldn't have worked because feudalism, the point is to protect
the power of the aristoc aristocracy. That's not the goal of
democracy and that was the dumbest point Wilson has ever made.
He, Trust me, when he gets into anything like learned, I feel
like Andrew kind of
Like, it's it's kind of goofy. It is very goofy.
bros and that they're the ones that are crafting the legislation
via think tanks that then go in front of legislators to be rubber
stamped and issued into Congress. That is the technocratic
>> Those are the people who make hundreds of thousands
or millions of dollars. If you're saying that the American republic
is fallen because we're letting the sworthy plebeian masses make
their voices known too hard, the complaint is the opposite. That
we're almost being exclusively run by elites. No, what's going
on is that those think tanks and those NOS's
>> I I'm pretty confident. I'm going to say this again.
I do believe that in a
like the degree of infranchisement doesn't really change whether
or not it's a republic. You have like a representative democracy
that I
h I think that's just always a republic. not quite representative
democracy, but I think like a republic is is a republic whether
or not there's universal infranchisement. They didn't have universal
infranchisement in uh in Rome either. Like not a requirement.
>> Those technocrats and those billionaires, what they
do is they craft mass propaganda campaigns in order to get carefully
selected politicians who are in their pocket elected by bribing
certain parts of the electorate. This is why you see the propaganda
coming out of the think tanks on the left for things like DEI,
for things like uh reparations, for things like this. These are
all bribes to the electorate in order to get specific politicians
to get elected who will then pass whatever their non-governmental
organization NGO uh or think tank has set up for us. This >> you
say that in developed countries, Americans are uniquely bad at
peing class, right? >> Well, no, they're really good at
it actually. That's one of the big falsehoods. That's one of
the big falsehoods of the left these last
>> wrote the republic and he believed in philosopher kings
ruling. Well, didn't he just argue that was the best way that
like basically if you have a
I think he he argued that
that like really like true plebeian representative democracy
where where most people get a vote is bad. I to be honest
Plato is right. Okay, we need we need philosopher kings now real
bad. The problem is instead we've got like Elon Musk. Okay,
we we've never needed Philosopher Kings more than we do right
now. Instead we've got like Donald Trump, Elon Musk,
Peter Teal, we're so mendous mold bug. We're so
>> uh riots for instance that happened in California.
Uh the no kings day was not organic at all. It was it was grafted
by 500 to a th >> I think the issue here Stalin sloth is
that there is a there's a discrepancy in it becomes very close
to direct democracy
when enough people have power who don't have any economic state
who aren't significantly like that that don't have a stake in
any way in the in the state succeeding that like they can vote
in things that are they can vote for things and representatives
who work against the well-being of the state
and I think there's almost no way to argue against that, right?
That's literally what the entire manga movement is predicated
on. Obviously, that's true. That entire movement is except it's
even more because instead of them voting to say, "Hey, actually
raid the treasury and give it to us," people are voting in Donald
Trump and being like, "Hey, raid the treasury and give it to
yourself."
It's like an embarrassingly stupid version of of the problem.
Okay, it's crazy. thousand specific NOS's and I read a list of
them and what they did was they began paying the peasant class
to show up to these things which they often do and they were
trying to propagandize portions of the electorate against Donald
Trump because he you're a citizen you have an economic stake
in the nation but if you vote for things that are bad for the
nation um other people feel the the cost of that like disproportionately
like you how do I put it
like there's a way to make sure that you want the nation to succeed
as somebody who's a representative or somebody who's voting for
a representative and usually you think like oh that's just but
there I don't know there are people who like straight
I feel like America's borderline got like like 40% of the electorate
is passively there's like a problem that arises when a huge portion
of your electorate is just passively in some way I don't know
how else to describe the
it's like okay we need some people who actually care if this
thing works or doesn't work and we need them to be voting and
running things or at least be the people voting. And unfortunately,
unfortunately, land ownership seems to be like one of the most
effective filters. It's not a perfect filter. It's really not.
That's why I think a citizenship test, some sort of public service
thing. They're just being manipulated. Yeah, but they're not
capable of warding against the manipulation.
This comes down to whether or not you think the manipulation
can be stopped. I don't know if it can be stopped. I don't know
if human brains are equipped to deal with the manipulation. At
which case once you approach that once you agree with that if
you agree with that that human beings are not capable of avoiding
the manipulation they will get caught in these bubbles forever
and never escape
then I think you agree democracy doesn't work and now it's just
back to realism. Whoever's got the most effective manipulation
tactics win. Yeah, sure. This incentivizes the nation growing
though. I would say a lot more. Porter
Unfortunately, that like infinite expansionism kind of changes.
I don't know how to describe it. It's weird how like so much
of wealth now is based on things that don't really exist. Like
not making material things. It's very
cuz it used to be a very obvious contract that led to like material
gains and science and all these different fields. It feels like
for the past 10 years it's just been like
making my computer better at entertaining me. And I don't know
like that feels like really
you think
if we find ourselves like incapable of actually creating AGI
which I don't know it seems like people believe we are going
to do it but if we can't make AGI that's like controllable and
and furthers humanity I feel like the past like 10 to 15 years
have just been like a waste.
I don't know but maybe that's I don't hear about like new advancements
and stuff. I guess if I take Ty as a cue, there are those rockets.
There are those Tesla rockets or sorry, SpaceX rockets.
You've been really blackmailed lately. I just think it's like
a direction that a a ton of capital is going in. That's actually
bad. Yeah. More Door Dash orders is more GDP. It's like, dude,
we humanity used to go in a direction like I think I think capitalism
was really great when people were using it to build and iterate
and and improve people's lives really tangibly. And it seems
like we've opted in the past like 15 years uh to just go for
better entertainment instead of anything else. Like the infrastructure
in America isn't better than it was 15 years ago in any meaningful
way.
Where where's like all the Yeah. It's like dude, it's like since
the internet came out, we've just been like finding better ways
to to make the time disappear to time travel to a desolate future.
I don't know. At some point that's got to end, right? Yeah, that's
also concerning. Although I would say in some ways physics like
like um
like transistor and chip chip upgrades like I think that broke
past what people thought was physically possible, right?
We've never been closer to curing cancer. Really? Probably not.
Entertainment slop is the opiate of the masses. Well, I always
has been, but I'm saying that like it used to not be where all
of the money went and now it feels like that's where all of the
money goes. But I in any case, if if they solve if they solve
AGI and it doesn't all of us, then that's like a new golden age.
Who knows what happens? I feel like if Saudi Arabia cracks AGI
in some way, there's like a singularity and they crack it first
and have control over like, isn't that really bad?
But Trump's going to, trust me, NBS made a really good deal.
Trump's going to get like $50 billion. NBS is going to get all
the Nvidia chips and you get nothing. You get in the app personally.
Okay. Amazing new treatments. Well, hey, I'm sure maybe medicine's
going forward at at the same rate it always has been. That's
probably real. I feel like I was in the tech industry and I just
feel like the tech industry I've become like fairly disenchant
uh disenchanted with. Yeah, in a lot of ways. I probably shouldn't
be so blackpilled.
Listen, I just need to be careful, okay? I want to start arguing
for like
lite type ideas or anything like that, okay? I just like debates
like this. We just have a little debate here. We can focus on
this. He's some type of thorn against their agenda. So they were
saying he's a fascist, he's a this, he's a that. >> That's
crazy. >> How is that real quick? How is that different
from what you or I do? >> What do you mean? >> Because
I wake up every single day. I go on to a live stream. I have
a certain ideological set and I get financially rewarded as an
ideological set by my by
>> because the culture was about to plateau before the
internet and after it has. Hopefully we'll make a rebound after
the Trump era era. Is the culture like Oh, I was thinking about
like you guys maybe it might just be that like there's some human
understanding like maybe the maybe the reality is like human
understandings hit a wall. I like the conspiracy theory though.
I'm all over the place. It might be that human understandings
just hit a wall but we don't have the perception or ability to
move past where we are. Like material science will never improve.
Our understanding of physics will never improve. Maybe we're
just okay. I'm going to go back in the debate a little bit so
I don't miss anything. But do you remember when like my worry
as a kid was like China was going to perfect cloning or something
and they were going to take over the world? There was like a
bunch of cool in science magazines about China. China was going
to do things like breaking scientific ethics. It's like dude,
does anybody even work on cool cloning anymore? Is that just
solved? Could we clone? Could we clone a human being right now
really easily? Just make cloned human beings. What about like
gene editing and I guess that's one thing. Crisper is like advancing,
right?
I I think crisper and like gene editing is advancing quite quite
quickly. That's
Maybe biology is a way forward too. We going to get like to the
designer baby era. That'd be pretty interesting. Maybe it was
to say that at the end of like the 19th century that it exploded
again. Well, it's probably just that you need discoveries. Have
you guys ever heard the conspiracy theory that like around basically
around World War II there was advancements made in physics or
something? I think I've heard this from is it Weinstein maybe
on Rogan was talking about how basically there were advancements
made in physics and something was discovered that it basically
if it was like widely propagated it would become very simple
for people to create like like planet ending weapons,
right? And so they hid all they hid like the advancements in
physics and it's just a fun conspiracy theory that like they
they hid all the advancements in physics and have been leading
people down a blind alley with with physics because basically
like the last like 30 40 50 years of physics advancements have
been like kind of faked to some extent and they're pushing it
a totally like string theory and
like string theory dark matter. These physical theories like
are actually not known. They're sorry they're they're actually
not real. They're like being they're pushing everything down
there, right?
There's an entire branch of physics went black classified. Yeah,
that's like it's like very very funny to Oh, Mukaku. Yeah, you're
spelling it wrong, I think, Riyle. But yeah, it's like a very
cool conspiracy theory. I just I like thinking about it. I don't
know. Like the idea that Oh, there are like major advancements
that have been made, but they had to be hidden for some reason.
Maybe that explains why there are no advancements in any of these
fields. It sounds like a game of telephone about nukes. Um, it
would probably be something beyond nukes. I think like the science
behind nuclear weapons is pretty obvious and pretty understandable.
Be something I think it's something going past like a hydrogen
bomb. Anyway, anyway, we go back to that >> born against
their agenda. So, they were saying he's a fascist, he's a this,
he's a that. >> That's crazy. >> How is that real
quick? How is that different from what you or I do? >> What
do you mean? Because I wake up every single day, I go on to a
live stream, I have a certain ideological set and I get financially
rewarded as an
>> Yeah. Like the idea that the government's made up like
um some anti-gravity [__] perpetual motion stuff,
all the conspiracies around like aliens and stuff come from that.
That's I think that's like a fun thing. It's just like a alt
history thing that I I think it's fun to engage with and think
about and like kind of connect patterns and then just let go
because if it's real then everything's but then if it's it's
like I I I think about it and then I'm like ah yeah I don't need
that belief. I'd rather I'd definitely take the blue pill in
the Matrix. Okay. I'd definitely just be like no this seems pretty
cool. I like this era. You live in like a dystopian future. No,
I'm good in the computer simulation. Thank you. Have a nice day.
by my by my chat and as a result I advocate for a certain set
of beliefs that I'm trying to convince a maximum amount of people
to believe in. >> So how are these
>> Oh, I see what you're saying after Samurai. Oh, that's
maybe a fair point that like we'll reach diminishing returns
with this internet stuff. The unfortunate thing is
like that might be true. You do probably reach a plateau. Like
imagine AI advances and it doesn't reach AGI, but imagine it
advances to the point that you put like all existing movies into
it and it can actually just create like fantastic movies on the
fly about any subject you want. Like what if it advances to that
point? You give it like a,000 bucks and it makes like an awesome
movie for you. Maybe not even a thousand, like a 100 bucks. It
makes like an awesome movie for you. All your favorite actors,
all your favorite topics,
your exact kind of humor or something. or it just gets like wild
and and like um a vanguard with stuff.
That's when everyone will call it gay and move on to something
else. Maybe. Maybe. I don't know. But yeah, once it gets to a
certain point, I'm sure I don't know. I hope things will hit
some some peak and move on to something else. We'll see >> people
because you're using scary words >> your propaganda. Your
goal is to use the electorate for different than you. Well, well,
first of all, I'm not a I guess both of us would be non-governmental
organizations, but we're not think tanks. The thing is, though,
is that what all you're doing, and I like to >> Yeah. All
you're doing is affirming my point. The idea here is that we're
trying to mobilize the electorate to put them in position or
put people in positions of power who reflect our belief structures
on the country, knowing that if we don't get our people there,
somebody else is going to get their people there. >> Okay,
but you're Okay, but hold on real quick right here. I think this
is the argument right here. Okay. >> Okay. Do >> Donald
Trump did specific things that are contrary to the Republic of
the United States. And what I would cite specifically is the
fake elector scheme by John Eastman where he tried to say that
the vice president's role is not ceremonial and that because
there's alleged fraud in XYZ ABC uh states.
>> That probably does have to be it. You remember that
Indian guy who went on Destiny stream and argued that that was
the thing that Destiny should be arguing like actually the um
the like spiritual void people have the the all is um like space
fairing getting obsessed with space fairing is like the answer
to that. I remember that when Destiny streams used to be more
than him just reading his court documents and talking about Lauren
de Lagona.
Those were those were the days before knowledge had to be given.
Okay,
>> me then Meg Pence can declare that because of this fraud,
these ballots are cast out. Therefore, Donald Trump is the >> Then
they had like another backup plan. Then they had a backup plan
to back up plan. Then they had the protest. >> I'm just
going to grant all of it's true. So what?
>> Also, at some point here, I am going to go through and
and deal with um putting like some segment together on him threatening
to dox people in the Discord. We do have to deal with that cuz
it seems like he's just going to keep threatening to dox people
and and harassing people in this community regardless of what
I do or what most people in the community do. He's going to keep
like lying about it. So, I don't know what that's going to be
what that's going to look like. I was thinking like an article
maybe or something. I just want something e easily referencing
or e easily referenceable. Is he still trying to Well, no. I
mean, not since like what, a week ago when he threatened to dock
Supreme in Cyber and then did dock some people. Like, not since
then. Is he still trying to? I I mean, unfortunately, I still
haven't like actually done an on-stream answer to
call it a report, make it 100,000 words long. Well, unfortunately,
if I could make a video of Porter Beller, I would, but I don't
have a platform to make a video on. So,
you know, it'll be something like that. I think breaking it up
into sections would be good either way. Um, I think that's what
we'll have to do. cuz unfortunately like I would like to just
you know
isn't wicked supreme face doxed well it's almost like we would
mean something beyond face doxing right like posting his address
name stuff like that but uh yeah I think unfortunately I think
he's just going to consistently like threaten the community threaten
to dox people and apply pressure until the community either breaks
or I don't know seems like it's an existential thing don't know
why I don't know why it had to this way, but seems to be that
way. So, we'll start putting something together. I suppose >> all
of that is
>> I don't I don't understand why he cares about the channel
the the channel that would talk about his court case.
Like, he just he gives a bunch of like I don't know like oxygen
to it. I didn't even watch his last segment on it, but I I should
go and um I should go and watch it and then explain that basically
he threatens to dox Wicked Supreme for literally no reason. Like
there is literally nothing being argued by Wicked Supreme that
is remotely bad. It's like pure petty spite based on Wicked Sup.
like Supreme being his friend before and
I guess him he he feels betrayed because Supreme thinks he's
a bad person,
but it's Supreme's never doxed him. He's never done anything
crazy. He literally just chats normally.
Supreme compared him to Cosby. Well, it was a joke, right? This
joke about how he thought he was causing it cuz he used to love
Cosby as a kid, then he loves Louis CK and he's like, "Oh god,
am I doing this?" It was a meme. It was a joke. People are getting
called sedicious for saying that the military should follow uh
legal orders and not unlawful orders. Right now, all of that
was illegal as treasonous as >> I'm going to tell you a
truth of the world. The only thing that's illegal is what the
guy with the gun tells you is illegal. And ultimately, >> you
don't believe in a constitution anymore. This is exactly what
I'm advocating against. >> Well, okay, but hang on. Calm
down. Right. The truth is is that even if I granted all of this,
if it is the case that power is seized in this nation by Marxists
at the barrel of the gun or it's seized by somebody else at the
barrel of the gun, the truth. Okay, so Andrew doesn't believe
in the rule of law. No, no, no, no, no. Hold on. You guys just
don't understand. This is you would agree with this. This is
the force doctrine thing. It's just something you agree with.
I he says it in this way to be provocative so that people who
don't believe in him in his ideology overall.
Um people who don't believe in his ideology overall will not
or will bite the bullet and fight with him.
But it's not it's not actually stupid. This is just forced auction.
He's just saying that like basically the way the rules work is
through force. That like literally the reason everybody obeys
the laws is cuz somebody says you have to obey the law and they
have all the guns. the monopoly of force. No, it's not saying
this. It's saying the threat of force is what prevents a lot
is what prevents like uh and the actual enforcement of consequences
for you enforcing your will on other people illegally. Like the
thing that makes that work is the threat of force
and that like any law-making society that just relies on, you
know, making prescriptions and then there's no threat behind
not following those prescriptions, eventually those prescriptions
are broken. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Take he's not saying something
crazy. He just says it in a way that most people disagree with
cuz they don't like Andrew. They don't like what he believes
in. >> Truth of the matter is is that that's how power
works. Now, do I agree >> there's not enough Marxists to
seize the power of the United States in the United States for
the Republic. >> Yeah. Well, you know what? That's exactly
what the Zar thought, too, because they thought they were all
nerd buckets. They thought all the Leninists were a bunch of
dorks in nerd buckets. And the white, >> just to be clear,
um
I don't think anybody who ever seizes power seizes powers because
they're like like
there aren't a lot of groups
that want to seize power and are a majority and don't seize power.
If there were enough Marxists to seize power in the United States,
they just seize power.
They just seize power, right? The whole point of like a takeover
of the government is you probably aligned coalitions who don't
even necessarily believe the same thing. This is what happened
in Germany, right?
the Weimar Republic
was it was like uh like
was it I can't remember which way the alliance went. Was it socialists
and and fascists?
In any case, it's like alliance
what do you call it? Like alliances between people who don't
necessarily believe the same thing form and they take over the
government and then one of them backstabs the other one. There's
a knight of long knives so to speak, a crystal knocked of sorts.
>> Russians had all the power and they were the omega.
Oh, nerd buckets would be they're like people who are just philosophers
who who
seem like they're all talk all bark. >> Lenist were a bunch
of dorks and nerd buckets and the white Russians had all the
power and they were the omega chads and they they never saw it
coming when they got overthrown. His whole family got drugged
out and shot in the head. Nobody saw it coming, Connor. None
of them saw it coming. >> All saw it coming for a prolonged
period. I don't think that's accurate. The late Russian look
at what happened with the white Russians and the white Russian
party. They thought they were dorks. They thought they were nerds.
They didn't expect it. They didn't expect it at all. And then
suddenly there was a clique through chill out. Let me finish
my point.
>> Andrew does this a lot. Andrew talks about Andrew does
the Fentes thing. This is what Fentes does as well, right? It's
not about being correct. It's about telling the the version of
history that's like sounds compelling and supports your side
and then never really ever engaging with the actual facts on
the ground. just being like, I don't I don't care. Whatever.
I don't care. Whatever. And then you start arguing abstractions
again. >> Let me finish the rest of Europe. >> Honor.
Just let me finish my point. They seized power from the rightful
power that was there, the Zar. They did it. A bunch of dorks.
Okay. A bunch of
>> There was like a 10-year period of unrest before the
2017 revolution. Uh, yeah. Well, there's been what, 6 years since
Black Lives Matter, 7 years since Black Lives Matter. BLM. BLM.
BLM. That was Marxist trying to take over a bunch of weasly dors
power for first. Then why isn't January 6 super based? >> Is
it not based because >> what do you mean? What does that
have to do with anything that we're talking >> Because
because you're >> I'm talking about the mechanisms of power
in a philosophical way, not the event itself. It doesn't matter.
It's irrelevant. I'm talking about our >> Okay, hold on.
Hold on. Absolutely.
Whether or not we continue to propagate the peaceful transfer
of power in a republic absolutely matters. We don't have a republic
and there's no peaceful transfers of power anymore. I don't know
what you're talking about. >> What peaceful transfers of
power are you talking about? >> Donald Trump gets elected
and they go to California and they start destroying vehicles
and burning the town down and starting little small riots everywhere.
They go to the ICE facilities of the federal agents and do everything
they can do to get them shot or killed or kill them themselves.
This is not a peaceful transfer of power. This
>> I really, really, really don't like internet politics.
By the way, if you look at any time throughout history, you could
pick any time in the 19th century, this is more peaceful than
the 19th century. You could pick any time in the 20th century,
the current era is more peaceful than that time. You could look
at a whole host of political intrigues that are infinitely more
up except for Donald Trump. >> Well, then can you tell
me why it is that Destiny's running around saying that there
has been more protest under this president than any other president
in US history?
>> Yeah, they do lead to violence. These ones have non-stop.
What are you talking >> I'm talking
>> I literally don't know what what what are you guys talking
about? This has gotten so far away from any like good
>> This guy, this guy is lost. This guy's like, "What the
[__] What do I do? What do I do? >> What do
I do?" >> 1992 and half aren't even aware of that. >> Do
you remember what happened with the BLM riots? Do you remember
what happened with the uh with the unrest of damage? Yeah, sure.
>> Yeah, they
spoke three dudes and everybody got bored. What the [__]
again again and again and again when you're saying that there
are now peaceful transfers of power here's what's happening is
mass polarization
the left >> it was a horrible argument by the way is all
a horrible horrible argument
of this right now yeah the thing is that's really funny Connor
is that the left right now is never going to accept a right-wing
politician and the rightwing is not ever going to accept a leftwing
politician that's where we're at we don't accept them >> and
so we don't accept their authority. We don't like their authority.
We resist their authority. That's what's been going on for the
last 20 years. >> That 50 bucks I can do like 50 or 20
>> on what? >> On whether or not the left-wing broadly
or the right-wing broadly will accept a president of the United
States from the opposite party. >> They don't see his authority
as being as being something that needs to be followed. They see
it as as authority which needs to be resisted. >> Okay.
But I mean
I is that very different from any other point in US history
that like hey you're the president does something I ideologically
oppose the president. The president is trying to do something
that with my principles. I'm going to pro protest that I'm going
to try to thwart his power. That seems like a very normal >> at
every level. They see it as authority which needs to be resisted.
Connor they see it from I mean you can see go to Tik Tok and
listen to these people. >> Yeah. I I would say nonviolently
protesting is literally accepting the authority. Yes. I don't
like this, but I can't sh people about it. So, I don't like this
via the courts. That's not a problem. That's the way our political
>> It is a [__] problem. Yes, it is. Because
once people decide that there there's a whole voting cast of
uh or group of people who put others in authority and their authority
is not recognized, we've got a big [__] problem.
And their authority is not being recognized. Okay. Si Okay. Six
Democrats said the other day that if the president disobys the
law and orders them to do something unlawful,
then it is their job to refuse the order. This has been labeled
largely on social media as a sedicious action. Have we seen the
United States military rise up and seize Washington DC? Have
we seen a rebellion that's deposed Donald Trump? Or is that what
I'm saying? speaking following his orders as long as they think
they're approximately legal. >> Yeah. Well, I'm talking
about erosion, right? You're talking about a specific event.
The thing is is that the erosion is happening because neither
side can seed the authority of the other side. In other words,
Donald Trump's not my president is what you'll hear from a leftist
a lot more than he is my president. They'll agree that he was
elected. They won't agree that his authority is something that
they need to actually adhere to. And the problem is, >> okay,
I don't like what this is going down a Andrew is capable of having
good conversations sometimes or good debates, but I don't think
Andrew Wilson and counterpoints is like a good combination. It's
just not. I'm sorry. It's really, really, really not.
Also, I want to watch Rules for Rulers. So, I'm going to fire
up Rules for Rulers. We're going to watch that and then we'll
be done with the stream. Rules for Rulers.
Oh, wait. Hold on. The video is called It's based on the book.
Oh, adapted from the dictator's handbook. Wait, wasn't this I
thought this used to be called Rules for Rulers.
Why do I know that this is the video I wanted to watch, but it's
called Why Do All Governments Work the Same Way? Oh, maybe he
says here are the rules for rulers at the beginning. >> Do
you want to rule? Do you see the problems in your country and
know how to fix them? If only you had the power to do so. Well,
you've come to the right place. But before we begin this lesson
in political power, ask yourself, why don't rulers see as clearly
as you? Instead, acting in such selfish, self-destructive, short-sighted
ways. Are they stupid? These most powerful people in the world,
or is it something else? The throne looks omnipotent from afar,
but it is not as it seems. Take the throne to act, and the throne
acts upon you. Accept that or turn back now before we discuss.
>> Is this the keys to power video? Yeah, it's the keys
to power video. >> The rules for rulers. No matter how
bright the rays of any sun king, no man, >> this is, by
the way, I think this is going to make the point about how
like if you have blocks that are large enough, they do vote for
other people to get other people's treasure. But that the reason
democracies work usually is because you have balances of the
power. >> Man rules alone. A king can't build roads alone.
can't enforce laws alone, can't defend the nation or himself
alone. The power of a king is not to act, but to get others to
act on his behalf using the treasure in his vaults. A king needs
an army and someone to run it, treasure and someone to collect
it, law, and someone to enforce it. The individuals needed to
make the necessary things happen are the king's keys to power.
All the changes you wish to make are but thoughts in your head.
If the keys will not follow your commands, in a dictatorship
where might makes right, the number of keys to power is small.
Perhaps only a dozen generals, bureaucrats, and regional leaders.
Sway them to your side and the power to rule is yours. But never
forget, displease them, and they will replace you. Now, all countries
lie on a spectrum from those where the ruler needs few key supporters
to those where the ruler needs many. This foundation of power
is why countries are different. Yet many keys or few, the rules
are the same. First, get the key supporters on your side. With
them, you have the power to act. You have everything. Without
them, you have nothing. Now, in order to keep those keys to power,
you must second control the treasure. You must make sure your
treasure is raised and distributed to you for all your hard work
and to the keys needed to keep your position. This is your true
work as a ruler. Figuring out how best to raise and distribute
resources so as not to topple the house. >> Yeah, I noticed
they're all bitcoins. >> I think he I want to say did he
change that at some point? I feel like it wasn't Bitcoin at like
when the video was first released
and now I feel like at some point he edited the video to just
make it all Bitcoin but then it kept the views. So maybe not.
Maybe you couldn't edit a video like that. I don't know. >> Cards
upon which your throne sits. It must always inspiring benevolent
dictator may want to help your citizens, but your
>> putting democracy on that sliding scale of varying key
amounts is dumb as
wait are you talking about the the the weird like guy with the
goofy hair who was doing the election stuff or you talking about
the principles in this video? >> Control of the treasure
is what attracts rivals. So you must keep those keys loyal. But
there's only so much treasure in your vaults, so much wealth
your kingdom produces. So beware, every bit of treasure spent
on citizens is treasure not spent on loyalty. Thus doing the
right thing, spending the wealth of the nation on the citizens
of the nation hands a tool of power acquisition to your rivals.
Treasure poured into roads and universities and hospitals is
treasure a rival can promise to key supporters if only they
>> Bought and paid for. Oh, you just watch the just watch
the what do you call it? the video. Maximus, that's not what
he's he's not saying that you Trust me, it's not it's not the
same is what you're >> Yes, benevolent dictators can spend
their take on the citizens, but the keys must get their rewards
for even if you have ga
>> Yeah. So Maximus in a democracy like even a representative
democracy
you still have to the the people hold keys like each person with
a vote holds keys
and that power coaleses around certain community leaders but
it is not just oh you pay the community leaders and everybody
else listens because you're going to see that this is self similar
all of these people if there's anybody below them that's a voter
or that is important in some way they'll have their own people
that they need to do the same thing with and it's basically saying
that there's only so much you could do with rhetoric versus actually
producing results for people and if you don't produce results
for the people who have your keys or give them treasure like
allocate treasure in their direction you can't just do it with
you can't just make promises all the time the most loyal angelic
supporters they have the same problem you just one level down
being a key to power is a position of power they too must watch
out for rivals from below or above thus the treasure they get
must also be spent to maintain their position the loyal and dim
may stay by your side no matter what, but smart key supporters
will always watch the balance of power, ready to change allegiance
if you look to be the loser in a shifting web of alliances. In
countries where the keys are few, the rewards are great. And
when violence rules, the most ruthless are attracted, and angels
that build good works will lose to devils that don't. So buy
all the loyalty you can because loyalty in dictatorial organizations
of all kinds is everything for the ruler anyway. Thus the dictatorship
exposed a king who needs his court to raise the treasure to keep
the court loyal and keep raising the treasure. This is the self-
sustaining core of power all outside his secondary. Now a king
with many key supporters has real problems. Not just their expense,
but also their competing needs and rivalries are difficult to
balance. The more complicated the social and financial web between
them all, the more able rival is to sway a critical mass. The
more key supporters a ruler
keeps me seems obvious in Banell. Um, it is obvious in Belle
kind of. It's just it's a good video. It's like a you try to
explain like why people are doing certain things. Hey, why is
this person doing this thing? It's like, oh, even though it seems
counterintuitive, I don't know. It seems like important >> Has
on average the shorter their reign. Which brings us to the third
rule for >> I don't even know what else we had for content
tonight. I don't know if there's there's probably not nothing
else here that I'm going to do tonight. Um, other things for
content were,
oh, the James Comey thing. Uh,
basically a judge ruled that the that Lindseay Hallan was appointed
illegally. Donald Trump could not just unilaterally appoint Lindsay
Halligan as US attorney. That had to go through the Senate because
she wasn't confirmed via the Senate. All of her indictments are
fake, are false, are gay and and
not cool. And so those lawsuits against Leticia James Comey thrown
out. Thrown out. Now, the one thing I don't know, and maybe Pisco
covered this earlier today. Maybe because I I know Pisco covered
it. It's possible that
specifically if they've indicted and it gets thrown out that
they can like actually go. They are appealing. Yeah, I have the
Pam Bondi thing. Hold on.
Maybe I should just do this on the way out.
Okay. No, that I just said all of those things and then hold
on. There's uh there was three little videos I want to watch
on the side and then we can head out for the night. Okay. This
video is good, but I'm gonna I'm gonna pause it because I forgot
I had this and I do want to cover it before it becomes not helpful,
not good. Tim posted a clip about it. This is war. HE'S THE >> WAR
AGAIN. This is war, ladies and gentlemen. THIS IS LAWFARE >> AGAINST
James James Comey has been dismissed on the grounds that the
prosecuting attorney was unlawfully appointed. Of course, many
people in the left have been arguing that the claim the prosecution
against Comey was going to be weak and would likely be dismissed.
It is being dismissed without prejudice, meaning they can bring
this case back up. But as of now, >> so I don't know what
the rule is here. It's being it's being dismissed without prejudice.
They tried to prosecute it. It was thrown out. But now James
Comey has to be beyond the statute of limitations cuz I believe
he got charged with like a week left in the statute of limitations
to charge him for this. I think it was 5 years. So what happens?
Do the statute of limitations reset or is he like off scot-free
now because they did a a case. They tried to prosecute him illegally.
I don't know how that works. So, I don't know if there's like
a refresh or something. That that was my only question. Is is
there like some sort of refresh thing that happens where they
could try it again? There was something about 6 months. Oh, maybe
it's maybe it's a six-month thing where they get to, you know,
appeal and then try to try to get try to, you know, indict him
again. I don't think it'll go through. I don't think I think
the indictments were weak. >> It is defeated.
Now, I think it's apparent to most people when you're reading
the news, James Comey had to have known about what was going
on. making his statements apparently lies. The question is, can
you get through this system? As the story went, the >> Wait,
hold on. I need to listen to that again. Tim almost >> had
to have known about what Now, I think it's apparent to most people
when you're reading the news. James Comey had to have known about
what was going on, making his statements apparently lies.
Had to have known about what was going on. Wait, is he I feel
like he just >> going to be weak and would likely be dismissed.
It is being dismissed without prejudice. Meaning >> he
just missed everything. >> It can bring >> It will
most likely fall under the double double jeopardy rule of the
fifth
>> No. What? He hasn't been found innocent. It was dismissed
without prejudice. That can't possibly fall under double jeopardy.
That doesn't count as you being tried
this case back up. But as of now, it is defeated.
Now, I think it's apparent to most people when you're reading
the news, James, >> my PNG vanished. Hold on. >> Come
had to have known about what was going on, making his statements
apparently lies.
Had to have known about what was going on. What?
That's just wrong. Oh, also, I'm getting really annoyed. My Nvidia
broadcast has like a super big delay on it. It's kind of annoying.
I have like an older version because the newer version was destroying
my computer's audio chain for some reason. Um, so the thing that
he's saying is a lie is James Comey, I believe, testified that
he hadn't personally authorized anybody to go and leak stuff.
He had no knowledge of that happening at the time. And then there's
like a meeting he had where Andy McCabe told him he that Andy
McCabe authorized people to do it. And basically the question
was, did you know or did you authorize or have knowledge of these
people like uh leaking this stuff to the press? And he said no,
which is true. It's not even like an indirect. It's not like
a lie by omission even. It's just straight up true.
And they are charging him for that as if he lied. But he didn't
lie.
I believe so. And I also believe that this was based on Andrew
McCabe's testimony that he told he told um I've not tried re
reinstalling Windows, but I believe Andy McCabe said he told
James Comey about it after the fact. And so it wasn't even like
it was incompatible with the testimony that was there. No, no,
no, no. He said Comey didn't know when he when he did it the
first time
and that he informed Comey after the fact. And then they asked
Comey if he knew or if he'd authorized it and he said, "No, I
was informed after the fact." Nobody's story is even incompatible.
They're just making it up. They're just making up that he might
have lied. And Tim Tim, that's why Tim didn't just one, Tim isn't
addressing it because one, in the indictment, it doesn't even
make it clear what the actual statements were that were lies.
I I believe I don't believe it's actually clear which statements
were lies. I think it's still a little bit opaque there. It's
not for sure. It's probably that one, though. And then he's not
talking about it because this is in in itself a lie. Comey didn't
lie. The question is, can you get through this system? As the
story went, the initial prosecutor, the attorney in this in this
area refused to bring the charges. So, this person was fired.
A new individual was hired. And now,
not true, guys. >> Here we are with the breaking news.
Let me get right to it for you guys from CBS. Judge, like, he's
totally lying about the the facts of this case, like the facts
of what h like the history of how this happened. He is completely
lying about that, too.
How's How's this guy such a loser? How does he He has debates
all the time, too.
This is just another case, dude. Pisco is going to go on there
again with a whole bunch of receipts again and just totally him
again and nothing will change. Tim won't care. Orders James Comey
case dismissed after finding top prosecutor was unlawfully appointed.
They say a federal judge on Monday ordered the criminal charges
against former FBI director James Comey to be dismissed on the
grounds that Lindseay Halligan, the interim US attorney who secured
the indictment, was unlawfully appointed to the role. The ruling
from US District Judge Cameron Cury,
is a significant victory for Comey, who has argued his prosecution
is retaliatory and motivated by President Trump's efforts to
punish his political foes. The just the Justice Department is
likely to appeal Cur's ruling and asked for it to be halted,
but Comey's lawyers are seeking to have the indictment tossed
out on numerous other legal grounds, including that his prosecution
is vindictive and selective. A decision on the argument remains
pending. So, we have the actual document here. Now, I want to
stress what we have seen with these rulings against Trump. This
is the war, ladies and gentlemen. This is the lawfare. Be it
Donald Trump's deployment of National Guard, be it his ruling
on immigration, judges have consistently ruled against Trump,
then been
>> Okay. All right. I don't think this I I don't know if
this one will be overturned. This could be because it seems like
it's a pretty broad
like it's a very broad thing. I don't know. I don't know what
Trump's power is there in terms of dodging the Senate for appointments,
right? I'm not sure what his power level is there, like what
the president can and can't do. But I think even if it goes through,
even if they manage to actually, you know, appeal successfully
and they get to try this case, they get totally ripped in court
anyway. There's like a lot of prosecutorial misconduct going
on here. So, it's not This isn't even like This is like a like
a thing they can do. And I don't I don't even know if they would
have thought this went through. This is the info warned.
>> What? What?
Dude, I'm so lost. I We're at the end of an eight hour stream
here. End of an eight hour stream. I'm ready for bed, but I need
to get one last thing in. Oh, the Pam Bondi, they're going to
appeal. I was saying even if they appeal successfully, I don't
think that matters. I think there's 0% chance that James Comey
is found guilty on any of these charges. >> I can just
get your reaction. >> More of the meme. I don't know why
you guys are referencing it. It's fine.
Breaking. Ag Pam Bondi confirms an appeal is underway after a
judge dismissed cases against James Comey and Leticia James.
We'll be taking all available legal action, including an immediate
appeal to hold them accountable. No one is above the law. is
being dropped today. Uh back in Washington, James Comey put out
a video. He said, "It matters most because a message has to be
sent. The president of the United States cannot use the Department
of Justice to target his political enemies." Your reaction to
the papers being dropped into that specific >> Sure. We'll
be taking all available legal action, including an immediate
appeal, to hold Leticia James and James Comey accountable for
their unlawful
>> What is your reaction to his statement?
I'm going to keep going on this. Uh
>> um I I feel like the question about unlawful conduct
there, the qu the follow-up question should be, do you commit
to charging all politicians, attorney generals, etc. who have
been found to be violating the laws of the country in the same
way or laws, state or federal laws? Do you vow to charge all
political
all politicians, all political operatives the same way? >> I'm
not, you know, I'm not. >> Right. Because like there are
other people who have done the same thing. They've accused Laticia
James of Comey. I mean, how many people have lied to Congress
and never gotten charged with it? Jesus.
Why can't they just file the correct way? Um, wait, they didn't
not file the correct way. The issue here is the indictments are
invalid because Lindsey Hallan presented them and the judge said
Trump did not have the authority to unilaterally um unilaterally
appoint Lindsey Hallagan as US attorney. So Lindseay Hagan was
appointed US attorney in what the
south district west east district of Virginia or something one
of the one of the US courts in Virginia and she indicted both
of these people. The judge said you have to get a you have to
get Senate approval to appoint her and so all of her indictments
everything she's done is invalid until she's appointed by the
Senate or whatever. >> No, I'm not worried about someone
who
>> Yeah, she essentially doesn't have standing. Also, I
think people know that there would probably be one or two
Republicans who might stand on business and this in the Senate.
I assume if Trump had the votes in the Senate to just pass this,
he would have done it, right? I assume he checked. Somebody checked
and they were like, "We're not appointing a prosecutor with zero
experience. That's insane. We're not I'm not going to do that.
Why would I vote for a prosecutor who like has more experience
as a model than a
What? Shut up and get the out of here. been charged with a very
serious
>> uh Alpha Kilo. I think this is way this is a way this
is like a mislead. So the the indictment they filed that was
not not yeah not presented to the grand jury was presented to
the head of the grand jury and like one other person on the jury.
Essentially what they did was they presented three charges.
The jury voted down one of the charges. They edited the indictment
to take out the third charge that was voted down and then they
just kept the other two charges. They confirmed with like two
people on the grand jury that it was the same thing and then
they signed it. So technically not everybody saw it, but I believe
there's not even an allegation that the indictment like laid
out different facts or was different in any way. It just it just
edited out the piece that they voted down, which I think is not
even actually something that it's it's not correct procedure
necessarily, but it is like kind of um
it it's like it probably happens a lot like oh we don't have
to redo this whole thing. We don't have to bring people in tomorrow.
We we'll just like do this and it's good and this is everybody
can agree. This is what we all agreed to. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep.
Okay. >> Crime. His alleged actions were a betrayal of
public trust.
>> Hold on. >> Has been charged with a very serious
crime. His alleged
>> it's I He's been charged with lying to Congress when
he told the truth. Goofy. Goofy. Goofy. Hold on. There's one
Carolyn Levit thing and then I think we're done with the stream
here. >> I will say is that everybody
knows that James Comey lied to Congress. It's as clear as day
and this judge took
>> I just wish anybody when someone says that when Carolyn
Levit says that like a total Why doesn't somebody just go hey
um hey what did he lie about? What was the lie? Could you tell
me what the lie
Just get them on record. Make them say what the lie was. One,
I don't believe it says explicitly in the indictment. And then
it's just ask them why do you believe they lied. What? Nobody
knows. Nobody knows, man. It's super incorrect. Didn't Didn't
the judge specifically scold them on it? I mean, that's what
people said. They said the judge was like silent and shocked.
But I think the idea was that they was that they they showed
an indictment that like left out facts. They did like some kind
of swap. I think that's what the judge thought based on the transcript
reading I heard. Okay. I think once it was cleared up, once people
understood what had actually happened, it wasn't as big a deal,
which is why the story just went away. Right now, it was probably
bad for them to do that. And with the with the amount of scrutiny
on this case, they probably should have followed every single
process to the letter, obviously.
But I I just don't think it was like a massive um I don't think
it was like a massive failing in the same way. I remember just
remember Pisco mad. Well, Pisco's going to be mad about everything
in this case, and there's a lot of things to be mad about in
this case. I think with this one thing, I could sort of understand
how this one thing happened.
I I would even say from a political rhetoric standpoint, don't
focus on this one thing because it is something that can be explained
and has a very like normal, rational, understandable explanation.
There are a whole bunch of things about this case that aren't
normal, rational, or explicable. And so, focus on those, but
that's just me. an unprecedented action to throw these cases
out to shield James Comey and Leticia James from accountability
based on a technical ruling and the administration disagrees
with that technical ruling. We believe the attorney in this case,
Lindseay Halligan, is not only extremely qualified for this position,
but she was in fact legally appointed and I know the Department
of Justice will be appealing this in very short order. So maybe
James Comey should pump the brakes on his victory lap. What I
will >> my prosecution was based on malevolence, says James
Comey based.
Love that Comey guy. Okay, that was all the stuff I had for that.
I think that's probably it for the stream. I'm going to head
her out. Oh, I accidentally just started OBS again. I'm probably
going to head her out. I'll be back tomorrow. We're four minutes
early cutting out, but it's fine. Four minutes. Uh, I'm going
to head out. I'll be back
And yeah,
should be more consistent going forward. We'll see. Okay. Love
you guys. Guys, have a good night. Bye-bye. Good night. Good
night. Good night. Good